this is jocko podcast number 292
with echo charles and me jaco willink
good evening echo good evening
august 2nd 2006
was the worst day of my life
ryan jobe had been gravely wounded
by a single enemy round that hit his
weapon
as he looked down its sights and then
ripped into his face
rendering him blind and critically
injured
and then soon after ryan was wounded
mark lee who had stepped into the
enemy line of fire to engage the enemy
and protect his teammates while
assaulting a building
was shot killed
mark was a larger than life character
in every aspect smart athletic
charismatic charming talented
tough and also hilarious
and faithful and loyal and obviously
brave
now he was gone
and in task unit bruiser we closed ranks
to get through it we celebrated his life
we mourned his loss
and then we loaded him on his last
flight home
his angel flight
and we got support from our chain of
command from my commanding officer
at seal team three our command master
chief the operations master chief
and the rest of seal team three backed
us up
and assisted us as we worked through
this
devastation
but it didn't stop there i got a i got a
call in my tactical operation center
it was from admiral joe
mcguire the senior seal officer in
charge of
in charge of all of naval special
warfare in charge of the seal teams in
charge of the boat teams
in charge of the training center in
charge of everything
and i had previously worked for him
directly for
13 months as his
aide to camp and i knew how busy he was
and i knew what his daily schedule was
like and i knew the demands that were
upon him
but i also knew that he cared
he cared deeply about the seal teams he
cared about
his seals
and he cared about me
and he called to check in with me
and to check on me
and when he called he he told me that he
was reviewing the silver star that i had
submitted for mark
and he was about to send it directly
to the chief of naval operations for a
signature based on
my recommendation
he told me that he was sorry for our
[Music]
loss
and he assured me that he would take
care of mark's family
he also told me that we were doing the
right thing
and to keep doing it to keep taking the
fight to the enemy
to keep eliminating enemy fighters to
keep protecting the local populace
to keep the pressure on
because the war wasn't over
and the enemy wasn't going to stand down
we still had
work to do
lots of it
and he knew that and so did i
and that meant a lot to know
that the admiral in charge of all the
seals was
there for us was there for mark
was there for mark's family
about three months later october 21st
my plane landed at naval air station
north island
with the last members of task unit
bruiser
to come home
and admiral mcguire was there
to welcome us home
to be sure that we were okay
because he cared about his seals
he cared about his troops
and that meant a lot and and soon
i was hugging my wife and kids on the
tarmac
but even as i embraced my family
i knew i hadn't brought all my men home
and that that burden will always be
present
but it helped to know that leaders like
admiral mcguire were there
we're there to help shoulder that burden
to support us
and to take care of the families of our
fallen
and it's an honor tonight to have
admiral joseph maguire
here with us to share some of his
experiences
and lessons learned from his 36 years of
military service
and his experiences in the civilian
sector
admiral thank you for coming by
jocko it's an honor to be with you it
really is um
it's been entirely too long since you
and i've been together we've been
through an awful lot together but um
it's an honor to be with you and an
absolute honor to be with you on this
podcast so thank you so much for those
kind words and thank you for the warm
welcome
well i'm sure we'll get into that a
little bit more but uh
to start off with let's start at the
beginning
which i believe is in brooklyn that's
where you were born right
you got a problem with that no jungle
forget about it that's where i'm from
yeah you know america's fourth largest
city four million people
i was a street rat you know grew up uh
grew up in new york city
and um you know people don't understand
that
actually brooklyn is on long island so
i spent my time in the ocean i
started surfing when i was 16 with the
money that i bought my first surfboard
with the money i got from shoveling snow
that's pretty wetsuits or at least
pretty good wetsuits well they were
loose you know but i'll tell you this
though jaco when i went to uh you know
buds and the you know folks out there
i'm sure you know this from listening to
jacob's podcast but
you know when you show up they they
shave your head completely bald and
uh when i had my head shaved by the
instructors all of a sudden they were
calling each other over
to take a look at my skull because it's
clearly a city kid
i had three concussions but uh yeah no
but uh between growing up in brooklyn
and uh going to catholic school uh the
sealed instructors were
easy absolutely nothing to do with that
but yeah what would your parents do
well um my dad was a world war ii
veteran
and uh what are you doing he was he was
uh military police
so my father was uh in patton's third
army which
till the day he died was the proudest
thing he ever did
in his life and um
but you know war was different back then
that my father
was there but i mean everybody was there
my uncles were there uh flight surgeons
and
they went to war together uh and um
he spent about uh he actually joined the
army in
1940 before the war started and
came home from europe after being
deployed
for four years and in
the end of july and married my mother
a week and a half later they've been
engaged
and on the 15th of august he was
shipping out to the pacific for the
invasion of japan
uh and uh so fortunately he didn't have
to go and do that
but my father then joined the uh
reserves after that and he spent 30
years
in the united states military and my
brother ben uh
spent 26 years uh in the navy as a
supply corps officer he retired
and my other brother bob was an enlisted
guy for for six years as well
and when i took my uniform off in july
of 2010 it was the first time in 70
years
that an immediate member of my family
was not wearing the cloth of the nation
so uh then i could say we haven't won
them all
but but the meguiars were integral in
winning the cold war there's absolutely
no doubt about that
so yeah so you're going up to high
school
what did you play any other sports
besides surfing no i swam
yeah no i was a swimmer and um it's one
of those things not so much in high
school but um
i would say if it wasn't for swimming i
never would have gotten a bachelor's
degree
so um you know the season would go in
the fall into the winter and i would
you know be on the dean's list uh while
i'm swimming and disciplined where you
know about discipline you teach you the
whole time
but once the swimming season took a
lapse so did i
and i just kind of got by in the spring
semester but um
uh nope i spent i swam for you know my
college i was the captain of the
the college team and i also swam for the
new york athletic club
and uh be honest with you um i thought
like most new yorkers
that i was going to just live and die in
new york city
so being a member of the new york
athletic club uh we were all on
scholarship and the new york athletic
club
um they just took the top swimmers from
all of the colleges
and put us together after the college
season and back then it was aau
and we'd have a swimming practice uh at
the new york athletic club
we'd have to go and coat and tie to
practice but it was right
next to central park south but we had a
stipend
a credit card for x amount of dollars a
month
so after swimming practice we went down
to
the bar to refuel oh it doesn't so
so the car over the course of a couple
of years
from the new york lavella club i'm
graduating from college and there are a
couple of businessmen that i knew there
uh and they said joe we want to take you
to dinner
okay you know so we're at dinner in one
of the steakhouses in manhattan
and uh you know my friend made the pitch
he said
we want you to come into the advertising
firm
well you know guys i'm not even a
business major what is it that you want
me to do
joe all we want you to do is entertain
the clients
i will teach you the business i could do
that man
so you know i'm getting ready to be a
madman and
i'm going into madison avenue my brother
what year is this
this is 1974. so so
when when you were growing up i mean
vietnam is going on
my brother my brothers served vietnam
yeah
both my both my brothers um and uh
obviously
you know i've had to make that decision
either graduate from college or you know
go into vietnam
as an enlisted guy but my father being a
colonel and my other just said look um
you're not that just
i mean you know you were enlisted man
yourself that's the hardest part but
in vietnam it's the ncos that are the
military and it's the ncos that do the
fighting and dying um
but uh my father encouraged me to finish
college
and then go if you if you really want to
go into the service you know then
go in with your college degree so i
graduated in 1974 but the war was was
over by then
and uh so my brother
from my father heard that i was going to
go into madison avenue so he was
stationed here
in san diego on the uss ranger and flew
to new york city
and arranged for an officer candidate
school test
for me and i did not participate in this
decision
so i was sitting at the kitchen table
and um
my father goes ben what do you want to
tell your brother
you're going to take the test for office
of canada school tomorrow
he's five years older my father's
looking at me okay
you know so uh i mean so i went down
there now keep in mind
i'm swimming i got hair down to my
shoulders back then it's all bleached
blonde from the chlorine
and so so i go down
and i take the test which i like the
sats and um
i'm very deliberate actually slow there
were a lot of big words that i had to
sound out in the test
and so you turned that you turned the
paper in
and they graded the paper and debriefed
the individual
based on and i was one of the very last
ones to finish
and it was a crummy office there in
manhattan it was downtown manhattan
right by city hall
and all they had was little little
crummy office dividers that you know
it's like 18 inches below and it only
goes up about four and a half feet
and they've got folding chairs in the
other side and you can hear everything
on the other side
so they're bringing them in and the guy
sits down he says well
you know mr smith you could take the
test again next year oh gee
mr brown you could take the test again
so nobody was passed to the test
so up there i said to my brother i i
don't think i passed he said well we'll
see
so i go in and i sit down and the
recruiters go
so joe you want to join the navy no man
i just took the test
[Laughter]
my brother smacks me in the head
he goes you're joined in the navy okay
uh and then the recruiters are looking
at me like what do you want to do
now my brother was a supply corps
officer he wants to be a supply corps
officer
so yeah that's what i wanted to do
so they look at the score and i look at
my brother this is my brother's proudest
moment
your little brother didn't score high
enough he can't be a supplier officer
so and they said well what do you want
to do i mean
this has only been about 15 hours so i
got the wheels turning
and now back then we were doing the
apollo recoveries
and the the the uh the the astronauts
would land in the water
and sometimes the recovery carrier
wasn't there they had so they had these
b-roll human interest stories so
recently
there was a human interest story about
the recovery and there were
two seals uh you know uh and who
were on the olympic team now i was not
on the olympic team not at that caliber
but because they were i knew of them and
one was in seal team one
and one was in udt 13 and they did a two
they did a human interest story on the
seals
and now keep in mind jaco this is 1974.
we have less than 800 people in the
community nobody knows what it is and
um they said so what do you want to do
you know what i want to do
i want to be in udt and clt
[Laughter]
give them a hard one right so the two i
mean they're just looking like
what now these guys were aviators in
surface warfare guys so they just turned
to my brother
um they said well we'll be back so now
they went back for about 10 minutes it
was probably like you know buying a car
where i got to go talk to my manager
they come back 10 minutes later they
talk to my brother meanwhile he's he my
brother hasn't sat down he's still
standing over me
and i'm sitting in the chair because i
was told to sit
right and they talked to my brothers
first and they turned to me they say
oh sorry joe but there's no commission
officers in unity or seal team
and i proceeded to tell them that's bs
but i didn't say
bs right and of course my brother smacks
me in the head again
and he goes joe they would lie to you
now here i'm a civilian i'm turning my
brother i go
they're recruiters that's what they do
you know
and they were lying to me as you know so
uh
they i wound up going to surface warfare
to the uss coronado
and i spent you know time on that to
become a surface warfare officer before
i got to
coronado california to become a seal and
i will tell you this
that um uh the demanding life on board
ship
by the time i got to bud's training i
thought that was good duty
and when guys were quitting i was
putting my arm around them and give them
a counseling session it's just like
you don't know what it's like out there
look we got a mini mart down the street
life is good did you have to go to did
you go to ocs
i did that what you did i did yeah and
how was the how was that shock and awe
experience uh well you know you realize
like in the first couple of days that
you've been duped
it's five o'clock in the morning and
they're waking you up and you've got to
be outside in five minutes and you're pt
gear pt
you know come on you know said um
no that was a great experience actually
um and
it was the beginning it was a tremendous
maturation start for me
to actually join the military go to ocs
uh have drill instructors uh teaching
you they had expectations they had
standards
uh and then also you know you were
measured and you had to live up to
something
and really it was transformational
for me and i wound up
doing pretty well in ocs and
did well on board the ship and um you
know when i got by the time i got to uh
you know bud's class
93 uh we had his usual bet you know we
started off with 147
guys in the class and finished with 17
and
i was standing there and you know be
honest with you choco
nobody but nobody was more surprised
that i wanted to be in the yard of man
because i told kathy i was married oh
you were the honor man oh yeah
but i mean i told cathy i mean we came
back from san clemente she goes how you
doing oh they're going to catch up to me
this week i know i'm going to get canned
this week you know you just never know
until you graduate
and when they announced where the honor
man was it was just kind of like
it must be some mistake you know but
yeah so
that was that one that was a great
experience as you know blood
buds is a defining thing and hell week
is a defining thing for all of us but
the one thing about that is it all
starts there it all shapes it
and you know every one of us whether
you're the admiral with his
folks in ramadi in fallujah or the guys
in ramadi in fallujah
whether you are the guy with stars in
his collar or the guys with
chevrons on his his collar we all wear
the same warfare insignia there is no
difference between a seal officer
and a sealed enlisted man as far as what
he had to do to earn that
now the career is different over the
time but it's one thing that
we all understand it was the crucible
it's a defining thing
and you go through that and um you know
it starts your journey that doesn't
really make you a seal
when you get your tried and pinned on
you that's your beginning
of learning how to really become a seal
and it takes and i'll tell you
until the day i took off my uniform i
learned every single day and as
you know the saying goes you've got to
earn it every single day
was there anything at buds that was hard
for you because if you were a collegiate
swimmer the swims must have been like a
jill
a br for you yeah
next question what about rob were you a
good runner oh
no no so so so
that's the point that really really
upset me chaco is that buds is a running
club
it's not a swimming club you know but
that is what saved me
uh because i don't think i ever told you
this either but i wound up with a broken
leg
um in third phase so a severe stress
fracture
and um uh you know i was not a bad
runner we
were up there the third phase we
probably had about 20 guys
24 guys in the class and i was up in the
top five
uh whenever finished time runs or you
know when you do your running that's
run back to the compound you're on your
own um but
um i was having a lot of trouble and um
i didn't know what it was
uh by by a lot of trouble i'm 10 minutes
behind the class in the classroom
but i'm running and you know you know
you know the instructors watch this
stuff
so uh back then we did not have the
facilities and the help that
our young uh candidates have and uh we
had an e6
uh corpsman uh and uh he told me he said
i want you to come in i had to leave the
class no uh
we're well into third phase we hadn't
gone to the island yet
but um uh he said i want you to go
across the street and get an x-ray
yes instructor you know you that's
that's always the right answer
so i i come i come hobbling out of the
the third phase office
and um the senior enlisted guy uh senior
chief johnny johnson
outside smoking a cigarette like any
good seal bank
and all of a sudden he says you know mr
aguirre stop you know and when
instructor tells you to stop you stop he
said get over here
so i go over to he says where are you
going i said well senior chief i'm
going across the street for an x-ray no
you're not
of course i'm not senior chief he goes
what's up
i said well you know i got a little
trouble he says i tell you what mr mack
you got a broken leg he said there's no
doubt in my mind you got a broken leg so
here's the deal you go back in there you
put your medical record in there i'm not
gonna guarantees
but if you're willing to gut it out
we'll see what we can do yes senior
chief
uh and so went back in there and i
actually
you know was able to i was always behind
in the runs
but i was able to hop on the uh obstacle
course
and still finish in a top five in that
because that's all technique
but we used to run as usual choco from
the compound down to the center
center beach and coronado which is
probably
a little over a mile something like that
and then you know and then in the water
so i would be the last one in the water
by light years but i would be the first
one
out of the water so at least the
instructors knew that hey i'm pointing
out
but the other thing i think that they
were thoroughly entertained that they
really didn't want
didn't want me out of the classroom
but you know um uh you know the folks
who are out there
instructors um uh are the ones that
really they are the gatekeepers
for who's going to wind up going to a
seal team and they are instructors for
just a limited period of time
and then they go back to the seal team
and the young men that they're training
are going to become their teammates so
for the most part they're sizing them up
not only to meet the standards
but also to kind of say is this somebody
that i want to be a teammate with
and if i get into the trouble and i'm
and i'm a left
is it i got one of these guys in my left
and my right and i think that
even if i was having a difficult time
there i was most fortunate to have
good instructors and and back then um i
mean
everybody was vietnam veteran yeah
everybody everybody
had a silver star um and uh i was
blessed
to have a medal of honor recipient as
one of my instructors mike thornton
and um and that helped shape me as well
in more ways than one
but these guys had known the crucible of
combat
and uh they were looking at students and
nobody really cared if nobody graduated
back then
but uh they were looking at um you know
can we trust this guy in combat
and i think that was the standard and
but i have to say in retrospect it
wasn't me
uh it was the instructors that really
showed me tremendous kindness
but um you know just uh it was not
easy uh being able to do the stuff that
we needed to do
at the end of training there was a class
most of it just before it wasn't wasn't
class 85 or 86 where
literally no one made it that's correct
what what class do you know what class
number that was
i don't but i think you're close but the
other one was uh admiral eric olsen's
class
uh wound up uh with four people in hell
week
and these the instructors had to help
them carry the ibs because they could
four guys could carry an ibs and
instructors made up their mind
we're never to let we're going to keep
in mind
there's got to be at least six guys here
to get through all week but yeah eric
had four guys when he
was his graduation picture and one of
the uh one of the uh
students is a foreign student in his
class so three americans and one foreign
guy
but it was a different different
different time back then
but you know the instructors out of the
back of their belk uh the um
um ball cap we made them quit
you know so uh there were standards
uh but they were pretty much on their
own as far as what they wanted to do but
i'll be honest with you
these are instructors that i had
tremendous respect for
and uh respect for their combat
experience and they were
they were great instructors because they
were intense
and if you didn't have the standard uh
even if you were making the standard
and it was tough to see a classmate go
but in retrospect you know they were
right
this guy would not have fit in to us but
yeah and then um so graduating and then
off to jump school which was
always airborne yeah that's it you know
one week cost crammed into three
so you hit airborne school i'm sure it
was the uh the
the challenge to keep your i'm sure
there's a lot of challenges at airborne
school for you
i can imagine the runs were not as
challenging as trying to control your
mouth talking to the
army folks no
no i i got called into the colonel a
couple of times
so actually so uh
for those of you out there have been to
fort benning you understand this
um uh you know the the the the army is a
little bit different than the the the
seal teams uh
to some degree and um uh
uh they'd have an evolution and then
what they would do is they would have
the the class line up and you go online
and you'd pick up trash
and well these guys are walking picking
up trash
and the black hats say miss mr guerrero
what are you doing you're supposed to be
picking up trash
i'm not picking up trash pick up
i'm not picking up trash off to see the
colonel
okay so i met the colonel you know i'm
standing there
attention puts me at parade rest what's
up
i said well uh colonel i'm a
commissioned officer united states navy
uh did you ever see bridge on the river
kwai
yeah what's that got to do with it i
said you remember when the colonel wound
up in the cooler because they were
making his officers work because it was
a violation of the geneva convention
and he's looking at me i said so to have
your commission officers picking up
trash you realize that you've got a
violation of geneva convention so he
threw me out of his office but
me and the other seal officers with me
did not have to pick up trash
oh that's insane
all right so you get done with airborne
school and then it's off to what udt21
off to udt21 so it was underwater
demolition team 21
and um but uh just like in seal training
uh all of the guys there for the month
now there were guys there from the
korean war
who just stayed udt didn't go to vietnam
they went to
vietnam as udt but they were former seal
team two guys so we had seal team two
and uh udc 21 and they went back and
forth but uh so
you wind up getting five or six jumps at
basic airborne
and um then we had a jump schedule
shortly after uh i got uh back to the
team from from fort benning
and we went up to fort lee to um uh to
do
do because in the teams back then you
get your 10th jump
and you had to buy a keg of beer so they
got the lieutenant jg
the nugget there who's so they're gonna
get me four jumps today
and uh so it was an old uh-one vietnam
single engine
and uh they they take the doors put them
all the way back
and you're sitting there this is a
static line jump and they take your
static line and they hook you into a
cable
uh just below the transmission on on the
helicopter
and you sit with your legs outside the
helicopter and there's just a little
um uh tape that goes across you
and you you get on board at first and uh
the aircraft is not doing any turns up
so
then the aircraft commander starts doing
the turn up and the helicopter starts
racking back and forth as they you know
and all of a sudden i look around now
these are all senior enlisted guys
and they one by one take their teeth out
of their mouth
and put it in their pocket for the jump
i was the only one in the stick of eight
that actually had teeth in his mouth we
went
out there and i'm thinking to myself
what did i get into
it's just in the udt are they hockey
players
so well make long story short it was a
long day but i bought a cake of beer at
the end of that day
and then what was that what was the what
did you do at udt21 did you go
what were you doing for deployments were
there shipboard deployments yeah it was
shipboard deployments
uh it made quite a few deployments to
the caribbean uh you know back then we
had a much more robust fleet
so we actually made uh caribbean
deployments european deployments
northern european deployments
so um i made several caribbean
deployments in south american
deployments but in addition to that uh
we also had time
uh to be able to go to schools and uh
you know just to
some of our uh uh cia schools and these
other things in regard to
you know how to do targeting and and uh
really because it was all explosives it
was underwater demolition and
cia were really good at uh their combat
timber
kitchen demolition and these other
things but uh i also then at that point
in time
uh choco uh with some courses decided to
take some intelligence courses and just
kind of
well i think that intel and naval
special warfare kind of go hand to glove
so i want to learn as much as i can
about the intelligence community
uh while i'm there but uh i had an
opportunity to um you know be a
department head there as well
and then uh you know be in charge of a
udt platoon which back then was
you know uh 25 men so
uh it was good and of course my uh
chief and my lpo you know both of those
guys who got silver stars
and um you know they school was in
session
yeah you know you're in charge as the
officer there is absolutely no doubt
about it
but you better know what you don't know
and be willing to listen to those who do
and these guys very lovingly
um i mean necessarily uh took me under
their wing
uh and adopted me and i'll be honest
with you even back then
um rudy bosch who is the command master
chief
uh at seal team two he he became the
command master chief in 1962 and left in
1987.
you know talk about basketball ball hogs
but i mean you know rudy
um but uh even if i was in uh
udc my lpo and my my chiefs who were
sealed team two guys
that's how i met rudy and rudy and his
wife then mentored
kathy and me until you know we were
close friends until
until he you know started suffering from
alzheimer's disease
but it doesn't hurt to be a young
officer who wasn't in vietnam
you know to have these folks here who
take you under their wing and teach you
uh and uh the best thing that was not
necessarily
the operational things but i think the
thing that i owe them most for
jaco is like at two o'clock in the
morning when they put their arm around
me saying it's time to go home sir
time to go back thank you
the new york kicked in then new york
comes out around two o'clock in the
morning after x
number of beers so
you did man so you were married to kathy
before
you went to buds absolutely well i tell
you what
you know you you know people ask well
you know where did you honeymoon
coronado california out of california no
so um
um they uh it's kind of interesting
that uh you know i was on the ship and
were deployed to the mediterranean i
held orders
to uh to buds and i came home flew in on
a mack flight into philadelphia kathy
lived in new jersey
and i went to see her first now this is
a dangerous thing
clearly uh i've been overpaid all my
life
and at that point in time i was making
the princely sum of eight thousand
dollars
but uh when you when you when you
transfer a pcs
uh you're able to take what's called an
advance pay
oh yeah which is sort of an
interest-free loan except
you got to pay it back so
um i got i don't know what i got i
probably got a thousand dollars twelve
hundred dollars or whatever
so um now i'm in i'm in in new york
um walking down fifth avenue with my
honey
and we walk into tiffany's and i say
let's get engaged so she picks out a
ring
i get engaged in tiffany's we get
married two weeks later
we go on a short honeymoon to uh to
saint croix
come back pack up the car and drive out
to uh to seal training
and um it's kind of a shock when you go
off to work one day and you come back
after the instructors have shaved your
hand
what happened to my boy you know but i
will tell you this
um no no i mean it was uh it
it was a different thing back then um
people didn't know about seal training
and but uh it was helpful to me to be
married
uh in in in that during that time frame
but as i said later on years on when we
went through so much stuff
that she'd been there from day one and
she understood the community she
understood how the community was built
um and people even today rely rely
heavily
uh on on her for that but um
yeah it um it's not something i would uh
recommend for everybody to be
honeymooning as you're going through
seal training
but um we did god bless her
well the thing about it is that neither
of us had any idea we're getting into
you know yeah you must have known very
little about seal training back then
yeah i mean even i when i went through i
went through in 1991 yeah and i had seen
one
you know the be someone special video
that's it there were no internet there
was no books
talking about it now i mean there's so
much information out there you can watch
all of buds and
guys know what the schedule's going to
be and all that yeah back then it was
just blind
they just ripped the blindfold off you
and shave your head that's it oh yeah
so um fast forward 20 years and now i'm
the commander
commanding officer of the naval special
warfare center of buds
so um kathy comes to meet me for lunch
we're going to go out to coronado and
have some lunch
and i'm on the telephone you know she
comes to the office
and um the secretary says you know
he'll be with you in a few minutes so
she's standing on the balcony
overlooking the grinder as the
instructors are
motivating that's how we speak
first phase class right and so come out
off we go go to lunch sitting there at
lunch now we've been married 20 years
went through training with me and she
said uh
i need to ask you a question yeah what
sweetheart
did you have to do that when you went
through training no
i said sweetie even then they knew 20
years later i was going to be the
commanding officer of this place and
of course i did that i'm so sorry
because i'd come home
and she'd go let's go to dinner okay
so how long did you do at udt 21 uh i
did i did
i guess about uh two and a half years
maybe three years
and then back then uh again we were
for the longest period of time just we
we got decimated after vietnam
not just udt but the whole community so
we all know
the whole navy you know safe to say the
whole navy and the whole military after
vietnam
yes that's true but then the the target
was russia
and we were going to handle russia with
the ballista with the nuclear triad
got it right and so if you're not part
of the nuclear triad although
i was in a nuclear weapons program at
udt i mean we had to deliver the b-54s
adam
um and um so uh
the we had 306s then that's it
and the three of them got together and
decided that we needed to send some
junior
officers out into the fleet as flag
lieutenants
and so uh now this is always a bad sign
when i'm i'm deployed down to the
caribbean
and the xo tom richards uh you'll run up
tom ridges comes down to this i've hit
that this is odd that the exo is gonna
so we he spent the day with us doesn't
say anything
and we're flying back up to norfolk on a
c9 we've got the whole plane to
ourselves
and i'm sitting against the window and
the xo comes and sits next to me
i mean i mean like i'm a popular guy i
know that but you know
and i think i knew something was up he
goes hey joe um
have you ever thought about being a flag
lieutenant no sir
no you seriously think about that no sir
you know
and i tried to be persuasive to him and
said look i was in the fleet for a
couple of years
i'm in udt right now i need to get right
you know after this i got to go to a
seal team
he says well the commodore wants to see
you tomorrow
all right this was stormy norman olsen
who got busted we just had a memorial
service for
norman and really he's one of the guys
that shaped this
he said you're going to be a flag
lieutenant it's as simple as that yes
commodore
it's true so i wound up going to japan
uh as a flag lieutenant
and wound up working for uh the first
admiral that made
uh a helicopter pilot that made admiral
and he made all of the apollo recoveries
and um every day was a space mission for
me with this guy here
it had to be exacting ahead of it and
you know we're driving along one day and
he goes i'm going to make you
the best flag lieutenant in seventh
fleet even if it kills you
i turned him i goes sir you're well on
your way
but i will tell you this um you learned
you learned as you know yeah you learned
and um
but the interesting thing is now i
endured myself to all of the admirals
out there and um
we had the fleet readiness board up in
yakuza hosted by the seven fleet
commander
so there's about 13 14 admirals there
and at breakfast you know they sit there
together and all you know
all of us bag carriers we go off to the
side
and as i'm walking by with my tray the
fleet commander goes hey joe
come join us it would be an honor
what's wrong with this picture right so
they went around the table and they're
telling me
that and this was really true at the
time
you can't go back to seal team right now
you're surface warfare officer
you've got tremendous potential if you
go back into the seal teams
you will never ever ever get promoted
this was in 1981 and
true at that time most of the commanding
officers of seal teams were lieutenant
commanders passed over for commander
we only had a handful of captains and
there was no real career path
you know for that but i i told them i
said well
uh look i'm going and the only advice
they gave me then well
go to pg school okay that was that was a
good trade-off
but um that was true at that time and
you know backing up a little bit about
my father being a colonel in the
reserves
uh he said the same thing back then uh
that
you know you'll have a couple of good
years but
you know you'll never never be promoted
past lieutenant commander it's as simple
as that
and uh you know i went to his grave one
time and
put my three star shoulder boards on his
on his tombstone
so that that's uh how long are you doing
that how long are you doing that job as
the aide
the flag aid 100 years i know the
feeling
no that was uh 25 months but i will tell
you i'll tell you man jacob
one of the best things about that i mean
this is surely um
is that i was the aide for ctf 76
and uh a young first lieutenant
uh named joe dunford was the aide for
ctf-79
and joe and i spent 25 months together
in the pacific
traveling everywhere together and um
then after we both finished that tour
you know just during the course of our
careers we stayed close
and um you know we'd see each other on
deployment uh
he's a battalion commander he wound up
you know being the
speechwriter for the commandant and a
lot of other
jobs that it well deserve but it was
actually joe dunford
uh and jim mattis that asked me to come
back into government
and uh i hate them both for that
no but but no but the thing about it is
with with both those those of two men
that i hold in the very highest esteem
and i also figured well you know uh
general mattis secretary mattis came
back into government and joe's been
there for 39 years
and you know i just said to them well if
you guys do it taking one for the team
i'll give it a go and we'll see how it
goes but i just could not say no to
those two men
but just want an honor and then to
actually get into the administration
uh and be the director of national
intelligence sitting at the national
security council
meeting with joe dunford to my right um
it's just you know you just it's a small
world and you just don't know
but yeah but you didn't take their
advice and you did go back to the seal
team that was your next i did
i did uh as a matter of fact and um
you know so the journey continues so i
went into uh
to seal team two and at that time uh
uh uh commander rick willard was the
commanding officer of seal team
two and rightfully so he wanted to
develop
an undersea capability so we
wound up uh now to be honest with you
back then
uh we were not very good we had good
swimmers
we had good athletes we had rotten
equipment we didn't have tactic
techniques and procedures we really
didn't know what we didn't know and
rick through our senior officers and the
chief of naval operations
we're able to establish a personal
exchange program pep billet
uh and bring over a french commando from
commander uber
and uh in my estimation commander you
bear the best combat
divers uh in in the world military
combat divers
and um uh francois was charged with
uh establishing a combat swimmer program
that uh to this day was the most arduous
uh program that that i'd ever been
through
um and um it would
extremely high attrition rate but not
everybody could do it but not everybody
could swim oxygen either
but in addition to that program then
rick also
you know looking back on this it seems
hard to believe get permission to buy
foreign sales
uh um i think so we were able to we were
the first was to get the dreger
the german and then we of course the
drago life jackets french
and there was a prohibition against that
because we buy american but it was the
best technical
undersea combat swimmer uh stuff that we
had
and um we did extremely
hard work up and i was just most
fortunate uh that you know
i had a department head tour there and
then a platoon commander
and in october of
uh 1982
we just got fast ropes so hard to
believe
and fast ropes were classified insertion
means
uh and we got it from the british sas
used
you know spend the night not a fortune
so we're up at ap hill and uh rudy bosch
uh brings the rope up we got a
helicopter
and um we're doing um we
first we're doing rudy is the repel
master he's the rope master
talks to us about this and now i used to
be on the ship
you know as a deck officer so i know
lines and stuff so i said hey yeah rudy
what's the tensile strength in this how
many can hold ah don't worry about it so
hold your hope
dude forget it you know if that was rudy
right
so um uh now rudy at this point he's
probably knocking at the door to 60.
um so we did a couple of runs and he's
the first one out
and um then after about four or five
runs
i just said he master chief this isn't
too damn hard you know we could figure
out how to curl a rope and throw it out
with a helicopter flares
all right so he sits this one out and
um so uh my chief bud dennehy
uh is is gonna do it i'm following bud
then i've got you know i've got four or
five knuckleheads uh you know behind me
on
you know and um we go out and
for some reason or another you know
buddy
the operative word is fast rope you know
so he's just kind of going slow
and then all of a sudden i don't know
what was going on
um i thought the helicopter was crashing
and i just knew that i was in free fall
and uh you know getting back into fort
benning i kind of criticized a little
bit there
but the thing that saved me is just
going to a good plf
i put my legs together i put my arms in
and for one brief second i avoided the
chief
below me and i hit and for one
nanosecond i go
i'm good then i had five big frog men
land on top
so i broke my back uh and that broke my
pelvis
uh so we're all lying there uh as a
bunch of um
uh rag dogs and it's dead silent i still
don't know what happened
so obviously when the rope broke uh the
helicopter went up because of
no longer had that weight and then he
just flared and went off
but all i could hear then was uh you
know my teammates my platoon
everybody's just kind of quietly moaning
and and i just say to the guys don't
anybody
move all right and then he goes mr
maguire
we can you know and then all of a sudden
i realized
i can't move my legs uh and
so typical back then our ambulance was a
nine passenger
van and the only thing we had on the
only thing we had
on on the lz was one body board
you know so you know we had to have
ambulances come in so
i got rigor taped to the body board
uh you know with your head down and just
to so that your spine's not moving but
every time they moved you it was like
with the pelvis was like cracking your
knuckles
you know you could hear you know um
and um then the helicopter goes back in
this land so the colonel
from ap hill comes and typical back then
we never told him we were doing air ops
which he did i think was a good idea uh
but he directed
uh the helicopter pilot to take us to
mary washington
uh hospital which is close up there not
not the closest to closest up to trauma
hospital
and uh so there were five of us loaded
into the uh the helicopter
and uh you know i'm a lieutenant these
guys lieutenants
and i i said to the pilot command you
know meanwhile i'm strapped to the body
board
and i said take us home i said take us
to portsmouth
i said we're going to be in the hospital
for a long time i said i don't my wife
have my wife in a motel i said you know
just going to take a little bit more but
take us to portsmouth naval hospital so
we flew there and
you know we got uh taken in and taken
off and um
they cut your uniform off and do all
sorts of stuff but
uh as we're waiting for x-rays we were
all in this
little waiting room together the other
guy's in wheelchairs
uh and you know there were two of us
with broken backs and uh
one one guy kevin blake uh kevin
wound up breaking both of his legs but
when he came down
he then hit but his face went into his
knees
uh and but you know we still didn't know
what was what
so we had one corman from the hospital
helping us out
and kevin says man
my nose is so stuffy he says hey doc do
you have a tissue can i have a tissue
so the coreman gets him a tissue and
kevin
blows his nose but he broke all of his
sinuses in his face
and his whole face came away from um you
know from
from the skull and we're all laughing
like
you know and and the corpsman just
running out just like it was it was like
a jim carrey movie there
his face is out here we got broken bones
and broken backs we're all left
you know always look for the bright side
of life right
yeah so what everyone eventually was
able to heal up no no permanent injuries
no no a couple of those guys left
but uh it was a different time back then
uh i'm sorry to say
that um i wound up being admitted into
an officer room with some retired navy
captain
uh but the troops wound up being on a
ward
and uh there were
probably 20 patients on the ward
to include some sailor who had been in a
motorcycle accident and he's on a
rotisserie
but it's pretty much a death watch right
so george ann mcraven uh
and kathy uh no the two of them were
the very best of friends and as you know
bill and i are
best of friends and uh they come to
visit me and um
now kathy's requested me with me the
whole time at georgian i said hey do me
a favor i can't get out of bed
would you go down to check on the guys
and see how they're doing so they went
down
and um kevin blake
is in traction with two hair dryers
on his um on his cast and
um kathy said kevin what are you doing
the doctor said i could get out of here
as soon as my castra
but neither of them had been washed
so they've been we've been in the field
for eight to ten days they had
camouflage on them your hair
so i mean no these are two
sailors mothers sons that been in the
hospital for a couple of days
and they've still got their matted hair
i mean so kathy
uh and george mcraven you know
got shampooed the guys washed their
camouflage off them
and um uh you know just do what you need
to do for for a fellow teammate
and um you know uh
uh i'm glad to say you know when
i've been in the hospital since then
unfortunately and um
uh navy medicine is really superlative
now but it was again once again after
vietnam
where the entire military was suffering
but um
i deployed uh that was in halloween of
82 and i deployed to europe in march
of 83 five months later and jumped into
macrohandy scotland
and then also conducted a major exercise
a flintlock exercise
with my swim partner uh chuck williams
and uh we
from a a u-boat german u-209
uh that we you know we it was a so we
had to lock in and lock out through the
german torpedo tube
which was um an excellent adventure it's
not for everybody
uh but uh when we left the submarine uh
we were in the water for 13 hours in the
baltic so this
is in uh you know late march uh or early
april
of of 83 the surface temperature was 39
degrees
but obviously went down about 10 feet
and um
i was just really glad that you know i
had a an olympian towing me
but uh yeah we were able to do
everything that uh you know we were
taught to do
and uh the two american swim pairs
successfully completed the mission
uh and the germans who the conference
were
very very good this woman neither this
one pair
were able to do it uh one swim pair
wound up not finding the harbor and
wound up in the hospital with
hypothermia
and the other swim pair bailed and
it was really kind of a defining thing
for the seal community
uh to be able to just say you know we
did that but uh the germans couldn't
speak english and i couldn't speak
german
to be able to do lockout from a german
torpedo too
yeah something got lost in translation a
couple of times
and you were diving draggers yeah man
and
so that's like eight yeah so the
wetsuits back then were
junk yeah so i grew up surfing in maine
and and i had seen that explains a lot
i had saved all my money and and bought
one of these modern wetsuits at the time
was an o'neill
source was what it was called and it had
an it had an embedded hood or
a hood that was part of the rest of it
it had a dry suit zipper
even though it was a wetsuit it had a
dry suit zipper just to keep as much
water in there as you can
and i showed up to seal team one with
this wetsuit which was like the most
modern technology and we were doing
swimmer lockouts
and i remember just i was in heaven with
this wetsuit
because the wetsuits back in the early
80s which you were wearing
just junk yeah
well and even when we went through buds
initially you didn't get a wet shoe
you know you guys get no wetsuits during
boats you did eventually after
uh as you know jock will tell you folks
though
one of the big defining things there in
seal training is the cold
and um you know you you if you show up
to southern california to see palm trees
yeah don't be deceived that water is
cold
uh yeah and um you know there it was
probably several weeks into training
yeah
before they get and of course it was
just pick something off the shelf
whether it fits or not
well we got wetsuits but the what's
again i knew
from surfing in maine and i was kind of
uh on the forefront of wetsuit
technology
and then i show up at buds and they're
issuing these wetsuits which they don't
fit you
it was an old-school beaver tail with a
zipper up the front i mean
they barely helped they barely i mean
they provided some
some bit of warmth but barely what's a
swimmer lockout
so you're in a submarine and then
underwater you get out of the submarine
and you go and it's a it's a very common
was like on the u-boat but for the
american subs
they have an escape chamber which is a
little ball it's a little
it's a little sphere that you're sitting
in and it's probably
what six or eight foot diameter oh it's
not that ball it's smaller
on the ballistic missile submarines it
is but on the attack boats
it's probably about four feet across
it's tiny
and you're in there and so you get in
there from inside the sub
and then that thing fills up with water
and as it fills up with water the
pressurize the pressure equalizes with
what's outside and you end up with just
a little bit of
air a couple inches and then then it
equalizes and then you can
the door opens up and you you swim out
of the submarine
so i i i deployed on 12 submarines so uh
but back then once you get you know no
good deeds
goes unpunished you know that but so
that's how i wound up doing the
german u-boat and it was different now
uh the u-boats up in uh the baltic
they're electric
so uh it's shallow up there as well our
our submarines
are deep deep draft but they're silent
just like trying to listen to a battery
and um so uh
it was a completely different experience
in that
german 209 have got eight torpedo tubes
up in the bow
and what they did is in port they took a
torpedo out of the port side and the
starboard side
so there's no torpedo now keep in mind
folks
that this is only 21 inches wide and
i guess about maybe 21 feet in length so
we had to link up with the german u-boat
uh
in the middle of the um uh the baltic so
now this was you know planned exercise
uh so we fly out of macrohandy scotland
in a
air force penetrating aircraft low level
uh
over europe and then over the baltic by
low level i'm talking about
100 feet or so and um we get
ready to go you've got your your
parachute on you've got your
your your limpets you've got your
weapons and
um the door opens you're still at 100
feet
and they tell you to get ready because
you stand up and then
the aircraft comes up just think like a
bell curve
it gets to about 900 feet or so and
everybody just jumps out
soon the last man's out the aircraft
dives back down
all right so you know you wind up in the
water
ditch the parachute you link up and we
all get together
and then i start taking one of my
weights and banging it
against uh the oxygen bottle so that the
submarine can
can through you know sonar pick us up
so we're in the water for about an hour
and a half to two hours
and all of a sudden as out of nowhere
periscope
periscope up it just scares the
daylights out of you so this is the best
part about it then right
so now we're in the middle of the baltic
the submarine is there
i've got to go to the side of the
submarine and tap on it in a certain
signal to let them know that it's us
who else is it going to be who else is
out there besides us
right so so so
that the when they do that uh they'll uh
they the torpedo tubes have already been
flooded they open the shutter doors
and uh this is uh not without great risk
so the the first swimmer went in uh to
feed first
and that was be my swim partner then i
would go away that was chuck williams
chuck williams who's a beast in the
water for sure he's that team too when i
was a teeth dude
[Music]
taught him everything he knows and then
i would go in
next to chuck and we're right next to
each other that i mean we can kiss each
other now
keep in mind we've probably had 300
hours together underwater
so far now then the second swim pair
comes in feet first
and that he puts his fins on top of my
thighs
uh and then the last guy comes in and
once he comes in once he's clear
of the shutter doors you know he
squeezes his buddy
who taps me on my thighs i've got the
weight
and then i tap the submarine so they
could
close the shutter doors so all right
we're in
now the torpedo tube is designed
to let absolutely no light escape
so even if you had a flashlight
you can't see anything inside that now
keep in mind it's 21 inches
we're next to each other and you have to
take your draeger off to get in there
no okay so i mean so no because the
thing is so now it comes to the life or
death situation
so so the reason why we figured we could
do this
is because an oxygen bubble is smaller
than the nitrogen bubble because of
what's going to happen next
so um we now we've got to lock into the
submarine
and come into the uh torpedo room now
the torpedo room and the submarine is
pressurized to sea level
but we're at 14 meters so
um it was so you depressurized then you
do water
so i got a tap signal we're all in and
then he said
you know whatever it was get ready to go
so get ready to go
means we all had to breathe our our
airbags are
you know down to as thin as uh paper
now our folks out there our bags are
about the size of a
football but that's it but it had to be
you know really sincerely
the paper and once you had it down then
my partner would squeeze me
and then the guys would kick me right
and then it was a
and then i would squeeze are you ready
to go are you ready to go and then i
would tap them we're ready to go
right and he goes here we go and
then they would pressurize the torpedo
tube
that would take us from 14 meters to the
surface in one second
so with the gas expansion um you know
that
so it was equivalent to me necessarily i
could do
you know it was equivalent to you know
having a a small
quarter pound half pound block of tnt go
off in the in
in the um uh torpedo tube it picked the
four of us
up uh and just the pressurization just
radishes
all right and you can hear the other
guys
so but it was dead you're okay you're
okay you're okay so then
then they have to do water and you come
out so um
you know chuck williams comes out and
then i come out
the other guys come out and look at me
like mr mcguire you gotta do something
about this you know and that's just your
that's what we're just gonna just
getting into the boat you've done you
haven't done anything yet oh no
this is showing up oh no so now we got a
now we got a three-day transit
to the target on board this you know
german u-boat
which is if you've seen dust boot i mean
all about it every everybody in the
submarine is at a
i mean the captain is 35 years of age
he's got the white turtleneck he's got
the beard he's got the he's got the jack
boots
um and there's sausages hanging back and
forth
now uh it's a small crew it's probably
only about uh maybe 30
and around the clock these guys are
working but
we were supposed to be trying to sleep
right right by the uh
torpedo room which is also the mess deck
so
we'd get about two hours sleep they'd
wake us up because they'd have to set up
for a meal
and then you know go back so we didn't
actually sleep
you know for a couple of days but then
as we start getting into the target
they take mattresses and blankets and
put them
all on the deck now uh and you know we
have our wetsuits and everything which
was a mistake
in the torpedo you know you're putting
on a wet
what wetsuits that you know in 30
degrees but
we can hear the um uh asw
craft um overhead so as the submarines
coming in
you hear the ping ping ping
and then submarine would just sit on the
bottom and then you hear
the propeller going by once the
propeller went by the submarine would
come up
and take us a little bit further now the
germans are helping us get dressed
putting our stuff on and because the
mattress is on the floor and the
blankets on the floor so
the sonar for the surface ships they're
not picking any of that up
and then uh one by one they pick us up
to slowly
you know load us in to so i'm the last
guy to go in
and um i mean it's just so as i'm going
in the captain comes
and you know to wish me well and he
could say a couple of things
you know you know joe you know target
bears
one three zero at certain good luck
and good hunting then he gives me a
plaque
[Music]
i got a stick in my wetsuit right so
we you know so we go through the reverse
and then we're you know we're
14 meters and then we have to go uh get
pressurized or no where surface then we
have to get pressurized so
that was not that wasn't as bad because
you're getting pressurized as opposed to
depressurized you didn't have the gas
expansion on that but you had to worry
about squeezes and some of the other
things
and then you come to the surface and you
know we're probably about
oh maybe five miles out and we weren't
supposed to be five miles out
what happened was that uh he couldn't
speak to me on that
that uh he uh viewed the threat from the
asw
boats and the picket boats too great to
bring the submarine in
and get uh uh get without getting
compromised
and we're out there and you know now
you're five miles off the coast and
you're in the water
and you're looking and you know you've
got your little ben's compass you're
trying to figure out
and you know where is it where is it
where is it where's the target
and i and i i said to chuck that's got
to be it buddy
you see that one area that's totally
black that's a giveaway
that's got to be the target so we
started going towards that
and sure enough there were picket boats
there so we had a planned dive that was
supposed to start
pretty much at the mouth of the harbor
and we had to start way before that
so we actually spent uh a little over
three hours
uh submerged uh in in this
harboring openness and um as we're
coming out
um chuck no we didn't need to talk
anymore i mean
we could squeeze anything and uh you
know we we did what we needed to do we
put the the
the the packages on the ships and he
signals to me i'm fried which was you
know
as an olympian and uh i
just said so okay let's go over to the
side so
now we go to the side of the harbor and
he
takes his mask off he goes i'm screwed
he said i've got this pounding headache
i've got narrow vision
i can't i can't see much of anything
what we did we screwed up
we brought additional oxygen bottles on
board the submarine
but we didn't bring in additional
sodasorb the scrubber
so what chuck had done working so hard
for that much time in the water
is that um he over breathed his rig i
mean we're working hard
uh and then the uh the scrubber
that takes the nitrogen out of your
rebreathing although he had
more oxygen in the bottle was no longer
working so he was having a tremendous
nitrogen buildup
and he said i just can't go on any
further
now we've only got about a maybe a
little quarter mile more to get out of
the harbor but we're in
we're not going and now there's there's
pickets up on the sea walls
waiting for us so we just kind of sit
there and you figure
all right so this is a northern europe
uh harbor
and the sea wall is probably um
12 feet high maybe six to seven feet
wide
and um i figured the only way we're
going to do this
is we got to get over the seawall get to
the ocean side
and see what we take it from there so
chuck's a tall guy and i was able to get
on
chuck's shoulders and jump up to the top
and then you know he handed me you know
my drager
his dragger and then i was able to you
know pull him up
and that the two of us just you know
lying there then we rolled over to the
other side
and it just kind of dropped down uh with
with all of our toys
and just laid there for about 10 minutes
to see and you know nope i mean they had
flares going off and other things there
and now the um rendezvous we had a um
a fishing boat that was from uh danish
intelligence
that was supposed to be at a certain
place and um
you're looking there and they're not at
that certain place
but there is one boat out there that is
another
couple of miles away right so
um i go now if we didn't make the
rendezvous
then you had to go into the e e nets and
then these are folks they fought world
war
ii so this was you did that they mean
you know i think i
don't want to go with it so i said chuck
it's not where it's supposed to be but
that's about right
that's enough i said but i said that's
got to be it
so let's go so we take off surface
swimming
in on our back and now he's kicking out
with olympic quality
and i know now my my hip from my broken
pelvis
uh is is kind of i'm spent so all i'm
trying to do
because my swim is getting to trim and
not hold him up that much
so we get to this boat and before we get
to the boat
we have to go back on back and then we
have to go underneath
the uh this uh the the fishing boat
and um underneath the fishing boat there
were chem lights
that displayed that told us this is the
right boat now here it gets fun again
right so we go up to the fishing boat
and there's a ladder over the side
and the guys in the fishing boat danish
um you know we had to give them a
certain bona fidi
you know no i've got a gun you know as
opposed if we're compromised right i
figured
there's two things one i'm getting i
don't care if it's russians i'm getting
on that boat
and two if they won't let us on i'm
shooting myself that's it
you know so now here you you're
you're you're freezing you're dehydrated
you've been in the water for 13 hours
they take it below deck it's a real
fishing boat so they got an
artificial side of the boat um that
they take off and put against the skin
of the ship
and they put the two of us leaning
against the skin of the ship and give us
a couple of these big beers and
chocolate bars
and then put them back on there and then
put fish on top then
no i want a blanket i want a gallon of
water so
the two of us just had to hug each other
all the way into denmark
but you know um it's one of those things
that uh
you know the recruiter doesn't tell you
that stuff sounds like a navy
achievement medal at least maybe oh no
they didn't give out metals back then
you know no no i got the breastfeed leaf
with bronze oak leaf palms i think
that's what it was
oh that's brutal it was brutal but but
you know
you know this jocko sincerely uh it was
but just to be able to come back in and
just go
mission accomplished yeah we did it man
and we did it the hard way
but but we did it just the tremendous
satisfaction you get from being a seal
and being able to do a really hard
mission and
you know even in my fitness report you
know when that and uh you know rick
willard brought in there
there are very few people if any in the
world that could do
with what these guys did this exercise
so yeah that's that's that's a freaking
rough one
oh yeah i did a was on an art platoon i
did a a
a recon we dove into a harbor we took
pictures
and of whatever ship it was up here at
camp pendleton
you know we dove in we got out the water
we took pictures and this was the old
school
you know film and we come back out and i
i had gotten that i had gotten like
perched in the perfect spot i was able
to keep the shutter open for like
minutes and just hold it perfectly and
so i took a bunch of pictures we came
back and then
and then the report i got back from from
my platoon commander was that you know
the
the the amphibious ready group commander
said i thought these guys went in there
during the night
and the platoon commander said they did
go in there at night this is
this is good photography but yeah same
kind of feeling and i
just tell guys when you're doing a water
op it's a real world up like there's a
there's all kinds of things that can
kill you
when you're out there especially in 30
degree water and 40 degree water and on
you know
doing the in and out of the submarine
no joke yeah i mean the class ahead of
me and buds we lost a
young trainee uh doing surf passage
with those big heavy rigs that we had
through the plunging coronado surf he
hid his head on the back of his
regulator and knocked him out and then
picked up the swim pair
and uh tore the buddy line and they lost
him and
finally got him some time later but uh
yeah i mean it's
it's it's for real and the ocean could
kill you or the weather
you know it used to be the patrol
leaders card that we had years ago
uh the first thing you'd start off was
listing enemy and the first thing we
listed was weather
so so what'd you do after that
deployment uh well i
that's when i went to um uh graduate
school okay so i
i went to uh the naval postgraduate
school and
studied uh scientific and technical
intelligence
and i thought all right i got 18 months
of surfing
and screwing off and um
so my brother went to the university of
michigan got his mba
for 24 months he took 40 credits
i went to the naval post graduate school
and in 18 months took 96 credits
of which i had three electives and three
three credit electives that's it
and a good portion of it was in the
physics lab
and you know we're designing the shape
of scientific intelligence i kind of
missed that
you know so um but uh it
was a great education and uh you know i
really one i enjoyed living in central
california dude i mean we went up doing
triathlons and some other good stuff
but um being able to complete that uh
curriculum then and then
leaving there and getting all of the
intelligence accesses that
you don't realize that those things
exist until you get into the secret
clubhouse
and then i was in the secret clubhouse
and i left there and went to
naval special warfare group 2 in
virginia beach
which is the oversight group command for
the seal teams on the east coast
as the intelligence officer there so it
was a very very good time to be the
intel officer because we were involved
in
1986 el dorado canyon the
libyan campaign we had the central
american wars
and also we did a significant amount of
uh work
uh in other areas there but um
you know that really is when i first got
involved in
deeply involved in intelligence but to
me
it just went hand in glove with being a
seal that
you know what to ask for that we didn't
we didn't really know what the menu was
because we didn't know and then we just
kept ordering burgers and fries
once once you realize exactly what the
intelligence community has gotten this
capability
you can really refine and the other
thing as well more importantly is you
know this jocko
it doesn't matter what you got in your
collar uh it doesn't mean it's who you
know
in relationships it's all about
relationships and when you had
you know folks who were there the n2 of
second fleet and said and i went to
graduate school with this individual
you know that that really paid off great
dividends uh you know for the community
but
you know when it came to what we were
doing in you know
benghazi and all these other places you
know i mean
we had built target folders for for all
that stuff and
when it comes to final jeopardy if it's
a geographic question i probably had a
target folder on it
[Laughter]
and then didn't you end up going to now
back to sdv
or when did sdv when did sdv form up sdv
team 2.
uh sdv team 2 formed up uh in about
79 or 80 because we had a udt
we had an sdv detachment in udt21
and that was siphoning off so much of
our money and so much of our time
because a great idea but
we did not have the technology and the
guys spent a great deal of their time
switching out the bow hulls because they
kept crashing into piers and rocks and
some other things
but cold and miserable but the other
thing as well it was a really good time
for me to
go to sdv because that's when we first
started to modify the nuclear-powered
submarines to carry us
as opposed to just having us go on there
and putting towels on the deck and
telling us not to make a mess
and we just we just had the dry deck
shelter we had the mobility improvement
project
which was a national mission uh to
the first uh dry deck shelter which is
this is a garage folks that we put on a
nuclear submarine
uh and we put our submersible boats in
there
and we we come out of the submarine and
into that it's like a garage
and then we go off on a mission probably
about 10 to 12 hours
and um uh in a cold wet submarine
and um uh it really i'm glad that i had
that other background
uh in that that i was able to bring an
awful lot
to comfort the uh commanding officers of
the submarine that you know what
you guys are gonna ruin my career it's
gonna be okay captain
we probably will but it's gonna be okay
you know but uh yeah
and then bill mcraven was there just
before me as uh
as a platoon commander and evan thompson
but um
you know also at that point i didn't
want to be that ambitious uh jocko i
mean necessarily
but i just figured you know if i ever do
wind up being in charge of the community
i'd like to know something about
everything in the community and i and i
really strive to at least have
one tour and have a good sense of what
it's all about
at what point did you realize you were
just going to do as long as you could do
oh uh when my wife told me that
so i mean this sincerely so
um i i guess i was at the 10-year point
uh
we we just we we you know we we did
grenada
uh vietnam is over and we're going to do
anything ever again
and it was kind of unlikely i mean we're
doing exercises and everybody was bored
and i was not oh well i don't know if my
old
former senior guys listened to this but
you know we're not a whole lot of folks
who are inspirational leaders in anatomy
let me put it to you that way and i just
figured okay
uh i'm gonna go to law school so i was
applying to law school
and um uh i'm dead serious i'm gonna go
be a lawyer and i finally get this
counseling session from kathy
she goes you're not going to be a lawyer
she said you are a seal you're a good
seal
every friend we have are seals i'm not
going to give that up for you just to
become another
crummy lawyer sorry counselors but so
so i just said you know just like any
good husband okay
so i just decided to you know jump back
in with both feet
and then you know you take it as it
comes you know at the 20-year point
we've all got to decide whether or not
we're going to retire
but uh as you know the service is like
they put that carrot out in front of you
you know okay i'll take that promotion
and then i'll get out
then they put another card next thing
you know you're old and ugly and you got
36 years
in the navy so was that your was that
your exo tour
at sdv team it was it was and a lot of
time at sea
uh you know on board the submarines and
doing uh
operations uh so yeah that was good that
really was a really really good tour
uh really become um
uh was that was the first deployment
that we ever made with the drydex
shelter
and you know when you we do do the first
uh there's nothing you mean you had to
write everything you had to write the
tactic
these procedures and the procedures
working from a submarine or
life and death procedures and you really
had to know and be extremely cautious
and
it really was the unknowns and you just
like
you go back and forth and in the
community
you know we we are a risk-taking
but you never take a risk you don't have
to so we really had to put you know
pros and cons of most experienced folks
and then sometimes honestly
uh pretty much we knew it uh it's gonna
be okay but you're still we're rolling
the dice sometimes
but the credit really belongs to those
guys uh
you know the pilot navigator uh and and
the stvs
to be able to go from a nuclear
submarine submerged
in the middle of the ocean and go you
know into
do a target and come back 10 hours plus
later
and find that submarine uh is a
remarkable
feat it really is so you know really the
credit goes to
those young operators hard men i still
think that
you know that is probably among our
hardest missions that we've got
and as you know there is not a wetsuit
thick enough
to keep you warm and so then what did
you go is that when you went to detailer
after you got done with that tour
you became a no no i became the maritime
special purpose force commander so i
deployed yes yeah so i deployed for a
year
uh with uh with the you know the marine
detachment and with our detachment
and uh got over to the mediterranean got
involved with another submarine
operation there
uh for the evacuation of the embassy and
uh of beirut
oh okay this was the second time that i
was in beirut i evacuated when i was an
ensign onboard the ship
in 1976 because the uh they were at war
and the ship pulled in the middle of the
night and all of beirut was on fire
and the palestinian liberation
authority gave us permission you know be
able to have one boat come in
and a junior officer uh to take the
americans out to include the united
states ambassador
and i'm in my my whites with my little
shoulder boards
and uh you know the the plo were pulling
these guys out from
uh line not let them get on board our
boat and i'm on the walkie-talkie
calling back to the ship and talking to
the exo
i said sir you know they're they're
pulling people out just there anything
we could do
don't do a thing joe just just don't
don't leave that boat
and you know don't do anything until the
americans are on board the ambassador's
on board
but it really to me uh this was in july
of 1976 with the you know 200th
anniversary
of our nation and i think here we are
the united states of america
and we got these folks dictating to the
american ambassador who represent the
president of the united states and us
whether or not he can get on board an
lcu
um and that was a pretty defining moment
for me
but so then
did it again at that time frame and
i had the opportunity to go back to
beirut
when i was the socom commander with the
json commander
and had lunch with the lebanese
commandos
and it was a great lunch we're sitting
there and i'm talking to the lebanese
commander who's you know hosting the the
the lunch i said well i'll tell you
general
this is my fourth trip uh to beirut
and uh the other three times i've been
here um
i never spent more than an hour out of
the three trips
you know we're in and out and you know
so we spent
probably a you know better part of a day
there in beirut but it was just
interesting when i went into 1976 to see
it
as a collapse city on fire and to go
back in
in 2019 i guess
and just see it looks like hong kong
except that they're they're bankrupt
um but uh no it's funny how from ensign
to
political appointee um but at all you
know it's always been a troubled spot
what was the uh this when you when you
went there and pulled guys out
or did the embassy evacuation with from
a submarine what was that operation like
we can't talk about that right now yeah
yeah
um so there was after that so you did
that deployment with the
with the with as the special force
commander
yep and then and then from there up to
uh uh to dc
so uh it was my first washington tour
and as the
assignment placement officer for the
community and it was an awful lot of fun
that you know you're the one person in
all community
making all assignments from ensign to
captains
and everybody hates you
[Laughter]
hard to believe isn't it you know but um
that was
that was a really good one i did the
best i could
to even the playing field and distribute
uh but
the other thing is i had an opportunity
to work and serve on selection boards so
you're a junior officer
and you're supporting the senior of the
captains uh and the admirals
as they make their selections and you
see the selection board process
and then you see who gets selected and
who doesn't get selected
and you could just sit back there after
a while ago
don't sweat the load man just do your
job it's as simple as that
you know because everybody's record you
know when you're up for flag
just about every one of those captains
uh their records are like manicured
lawns
but not everybody's gonna get it and he
just forget doesn't matter
if you're gonna get it you're gonna get
it but if not just relax and just do
your job and really
took an awful lot of pressure off there
but um
yeah that was a time uh uh that
then we went up with um uh uh
first gulf war so wound up leaving there
and going down to uh dev grew as the
deputy commander
and then how many how many years did you
spend down there i spent uh two years
down there
and then um uh left to take over
commanding officer seal team two
now during this time would you say that
this is a time where you know you had uh
the first gulf war happen are seals
starting to kind of
kind of become popular yet i mean i came
in in 1991 as we mentioned as i
mentioned earlier i mean there was
the the navy seals movie which i'm sure
echo charles likes the navy seals movie
i think came out
in nineteen ninety one yeah mike said
chuck forrest movie
yeah yeah but there was still not a lot
of
not a lot of popularity wasn't a big
deal yet no so you know um
um don't want to have a history lesson
for everybody out there but
because of the failure of the iranian
hostage
rescue mission uh in april of 1980
and then compounded by what happened in
grenada
that the civilian side of the house
and made the decision that especially
because of the failure of the iranian
hostage rescue mission
that if we as a nation want to have an
organization
that be able to conduct no failed
missions that we need to be serious
about this
and there has to be one command that's
organized
trained and equipped to be able to do
that that started shaping
the the community but we were still in
the navy the army was still in the army
and through the department of defense
appropriation act
of 1987 senators nun
and cohen tacked on the end of that
appropriations bill
the establishment of united states
special operations command
and bringing in the navy seals
army special forces rangers and as uh
160th
uh and air force commandos under united
states special operations command
so then we had our own line of
money for for for unique but be honest
with you
um at that time um my friend tom coulter
who mentioned that okay once once the
seals came into united states special
operations command tommy goes
well congratulations we're now in the
bottom of two food chains
pretty much we were you know um but um
uh we still in spite of that uh
the resources didn't flow and um
the active duty military did not
necessarily want to have this
and if they did they wanted to have it
three-star command
you know it's close to washington and it
was our civilians
that said no we know the military it's
got to be a four-star and um
well actually probably had an awful lot
to do with a powerful florida delegation
more than anything else that we wound up
in mcdill
but um it it took quite a while and we
would just
be calming and uh but uh the leaders of
the community made very very good
decisions
on with the limited resources we had uh
and we had other opportunities
to do away with certain types of things
that
we as a community did and one of them
was you know unconventional warfare that
the special the green berets were going
to do away with that
and luckily they decided not to so when
9 11 happened
and they were able to send the fifth
special forces in you know with john
mulholland as the group commander and
the other young folks that wound up
being the horse soldiers but
that war was a defining
thing for the community unfortunately we
paid a heavy toll
to be where we are today but when
the opportunity presented itself for
both afghanistan and iraq
special operations mentality and
capability was at a premium
and we were ready at that time to do
that
and luckily the active duty military had
come around
as well as the senior civilians and
completely changed the resourcing for
united states special operations command
and i have to say really gave us all the
tools necessary and bent over backwards
to make us as successful as we possibly
could be
and we were carrying all the water
and um so she said
back then nobody knew who we were now
everybody knows
who we are but that also has got to do
with the tax that we paid
and the brave people that you mentioned
a little bit earlier who
you know and if i could talk about that
just a little bit um
with mark lee uh and and ryan
so uh you know jaco mentioned about uh
me welcoming
the uh the men home from combat but i
also giaco was already deployed to iraq
and i would also see all of the guys off
before they got on the plane
and left so jaco's got a bunch of guys
from his task unit i didn't want to
bother them they're talking to their
wives
and then it's time to kind of go out to
the plane
and um so we're standing around went out
of the plane i said look guys
one last thing i said the genie's here
rub the lamp make your wish you know and
and guys some folks are reluctant to
talk to a guy with two stars in his
collar
and now mark lee was a new guy this was
his first deployment
and mark lee comes up he says hey
admiral i want to talk to you
all right what is it there petty officer
lee he says you know we're over there
we're fighting the war and we're these
humvees and these humvees are not air
conditioned we need air-conditioned
humvees
well mark i tell you what you know
you're in a war
and you just can't stick an air
conditioner in there because if a bomb
goes off you might wind up eating it
so let me do this let me go to united
states special operations command i'll
talk to general brown
and see what we can do and i went back
to my office i called general doug brown
who was our socom commander
he says look got it i got it that was
his big i got it
but he said but we have to do this smart
and
we wound up with air-conditioned humvees
in iraq
because mark lee asked for that now
um and to me you know as the admiral
you work for the men and if that's what
they needed
that's what they got but one of the most
moving things in my life
um was when mark came home
uh to san diego so when you come home
you get flown into dover uh and then
from dover to san diego
so there were a bunch of us that went
down there to meet his body as it came
off this commercial plane
and um there were folks at san diego
airport
were very kind to us and let us uh you
know come down
so now everybody had to remain on board
the plane with the exception of
our escort officers that escort mark's
body back
uh and i'm down there with the master
chief and
um and the body comes off
and i mean all of a sudden i realize
it's dead silent in the airport there's
no planes moving
there's no cars moving i mean i just i
was so focused on the coffin coming off
and then i look up in the terminal and
everybody's pressed against the glass i
mean everywhere
and i one of the report i said
what's going on i said we stopped
everything
we stopped everything and they made an
announcement in the airport
uh the first seal who was killed in iraq
is coming home why don't we all go out
there and welcome him home
and um that really that was that was
remarkable and as far as uh
you know ryan jobe i mean you had to
know ryan folks i mean ryan was just
indomitable absolutely indomitable so
now here he lost his vision
and he's in a bethesda naval hospital
so i just coincidentally i had to i was
going to be there anyhow
because we had a navy cross ceremony for
uh two of our uh
uh seals that were with uh michael
murphy
uh in um operation red wings who were
killed or not they were they were
posthumously receiving the navy cross we
had a big ceremony
planned uh at the navy memorial so a few
of us in town
we go to visit uh ryan who is at the
bethesda naval hospital now we go there
and kathy's with me uh and he's asleep
and there's a woman there it turns out
to be ryan's mother
all right so uh go up and he wakes up
and he goes hey hey hey guys so of
course
all the knuckleheads go in and we start
talking now he's blind
um and but he's he's himself
and even maybe a little more yeah yeah
yeah
i don't know i don't know who did this
i'm talking to you know mrs jobe and you
know taking care of your son and
we still didn't know what his
disposition was going to be i mean he
just came out of combat
he'd only been in the hospital for a
couple of days and um
so somebody says to him hey ryan we're
going to have a major ceremony at the
navy memorial for the couple of guys
they'll receive in the navy cross you
want to come
yeah i'm in now he's blind so he can't
see this
his mother just points to me with the
old you outside
so she drags me into the lobby and
she has got her fingers in my chest
right
my son just lost his vision yes mr job i
got yes mr joe we got it he does miss a
job we got it
so um uh i said mr joe look
i'm not gonna but if if our teammate
wants to go
i mean it's up to you i'm not going to
get involved but i guarantee you
we will have a car for him we will have
a place for him and we will have a big
bad seal who will escort him
do you remember who you sent home to bs
escort i sent three guys home
i'm not sure which one well one was the
american sniper right so
um so um so i i don't know what's going
to happen
but i mean this is a very moving thing
because we got the gold star families
there and
everybody was there it was a sunset
ceremony in washington dc
and um the secretary of the navy the sec
the chief of naval operations all of
washington senators
uh and i come out and the lights are on
me
and it's a semi-circle amphitheater and
as i'm talking welcoming everybody
i start over the right where is he where
is he where is he where is he where is
he
and as i'm talking and i'm scanning the
crowd and all the way over the left at
an end seat
there's one individual who has his head
turned to the side
i realize it's ryan so he can hear me
all right and i'm kind of looking i
figured all right
and then who stands up behind him right
i got him
chris i got him chris kyle oh my god
okay he's in good shape there
you know so uh we went we went through
that and i got to tell you
um the ceremony was moving but we had a
reception after that
and then we went down to the memorial
for reception
and you know don't frogmen that we are
you know we got you know he's blind
you know put him in a chair so it was
almost like animal house when they come
into the delta house you've got the
nerds that they just got to stick to the
side just sit you know
so we keep trying to get ryan and
meanwhile
now keep in mind he's two weeks since
he's lost his vision
um and there are hundreds of people
there
and he's just walking around the crowd
and of course i'm on him now
and everybody's gonna i'm on him and and
he bumps into this woman
and you know she goes oh excuse me you
know hi
i'm ryan who are you hi ryan i'm barbara
boxer
he'd have a clue that it was a senator
and he just started chatting her up i
think
my god you know so um uh
it was a wonderful reception and i
stayed till the last gold star parent
left
and i'm fried i gotta be honest with you
because i had to do navy business there
today and then you know and
you're on it and it was emotional as
could be as you can that emotion is just
raining
so um um i i forget if it was danny
dietz's uh family or
uh axelsson's family that that left the
last and i just figured okay
i turned to kathy i said all right baby
let's
let's get back to the hotel she goes oh
no she says all your men
are at the irish pub you got to go have
at least a beer with the boys
you know you know my name is maguire it
didn't take
so i go into this bar and it is
packed packed so of course the guys are
being nice to kind of make a way for me
and kathy
and up against the bar with the beer in
his hand
and his elbow on the bar is ryan job
drinking a beer just being one of the
boys
but one of my favorite stories about
ryan
um after he he got medically retired
he became very good friends with our
four-star commander general doug brown
and so he calls up demo brown
and he says hey sir um i'm going to
climb mount mckinley
i'd like you to come with me
uh well you know ryan um i'm i'm
in my 60s right now i don't know if i
could do that did general brown told me
this he goes
general brown i'm blind you've got no
excuse
you know so just i mean i said
indomitable
just wonderful just an inspiration yeah
one inspiration
both with chris chris as well an
inspirational person yeah
i i remember you know you said he was
medically retired but there was a time
where he was not sure if he was going to
medically retire right
and you know i he he said to me he said
well you know
can i stay in and i said well i don't
know but i know someone that does know
and i came by to see you and i said hey
there's a chance that ryan wants to just
stay in
and you looked at me and said then he
stays in yeah
now my thought was um when you look at
your mirror
and you see yourself you see a seal
and my thought was i don't
and have any one of us telling our
teammate he no longer can
do it our teammate has to come to that
realization
on his own and i just thought sooner or
later
i mean it's just hard to make that break
especially you know you're coming from
combat going through all this stuff
sooner or later you realize you know
of course i learned that from tommy
norris uh tommy was
one of our medal of honor recipients
from vietnam and uh tommy was
severely wounded uh but because he was a
medal of honor recipient
that you know tommy you could stay and
tom made the decision
uh i could stay but i don't think i'm a
full-up round anymore and i just you
know and
so he made that decision as well so i
learned that years ago and i just
thought
let my teammate decide when it's time
for them to go
yeah that was that was awesome for him
to have that option and for him to know
that
we as long as he wanted to be in the
teams he would be in the teams
that was freaking awesome um
where were we we were at what you were
you were about to take over seal team
two
well i took over seal team two and uh
left there and uh i had the misfortune
of getting deep selected for captain
but um yeah so i'm i'm deployed on
another submarine
uh with the with the seal team down in
the caribbean so
we've been we've been at sea now
probably submerged for a week
and you know as you know giaco we when
you finally finish you come to the
surface they put the uh
antenna up and you download the the
traffic
so um we're just we've gone admit now
we're up in the sale that the submarine
is running on the surface
and you know you folks you see pictures
like that and recruiting things where
the folks are up there so
i'm up in the sale with the commanding
office of the submarine and the
guys are in the uh just aft of the sale
putting our you know boats together and
some other stuff
and um uh the uh sound powered phone
rigs
which on the on the submarine the
captain picks up the phone you know
captain
and um he's listening and he starts
looking at me
and i figured oh god what did my guys do
now you know and um uh
he hangs up the phone uh and he looks at
me goes
we just got to message um you you just
got selected for captain
i said that can't be i'm not eligible
for another two years
he goes well what's your year group i
told him because damn chose so is mine
so so with that um i wound up
you know not staying as long as i would
have liked to but uh i left there and
then went to uh
uh uh got selected for uh harvard as a
national security fellow up there
and that was another remedial education
program for me
you know the part that guts me about
harvard really i mean it's got a good
reputation but
who knew the spelling counts
[Laughter]
so what are you how long are you up
there for 13 months so it was a one-year
fellowship
but it was remarkable so i had i had
um officer rank i was a member of the
faculty club
uh and it was just great to be able to
have my mother take my mother to the
faculty club
and just tell her you know even c
students can make it to the harvard
faculty clubs
you know so but um
it was really great because it was small
seminars
focused on what i was up there really to
do is advanced research in national
security
but the folks that i had up there at the
kennedy school
is really the holding tank for
government uh they were either former
secretaries former ambassadors
and i became because one you're a seal
and i just and had the rank that i was
included in
everything there um they're just really
remarkable
uh that um you know some of the seminars
i was in i had to put
a maybe once a week because we had to
take turns submitting a memorandum
and uh that would then go to the two
professors who
one would be the former deputy secretary
of state and then
was you know an undersecretary of
defense and they'd go through this dart
they're going to go
joe you dope you can't say that
they're going to leak that to the
washington post and honest to goodness
like
here's how you say it without you know
indicting i mean just really
good practical stuff but um
because i got included in everything
this is at a time when um
ted kennedy was still alive and the
senator from massachusetts and uh
john john was around and they'd come to
the kennedy school all the time but
senator kennedy's sister was the
ambassador to ireland
and the kennedy family invited jerry
adams to come to
boston and then he gave a lecture
in the evening at the kennedy school and
and then a small dinner so
you know these were all meredith
professors
would you like to come joe boy would i
you know
and we had dinner there were only about
eight of us at dinner and he was holding
court
and i got to tell you i was just sitting
there watching and thinking
no wonder i mean this guy these are all
senior emeritus harvard professors and
they were eating out of his hand
uh and i think this guy's good this
guy's real good um
so then our our four-star at that point
in time general downing
came up to visit he came up on a regular
basis to harvard
and so what have you been up to well i
did it with jerry adams
that didn't go good you know because
it's just you know joe
he's one of the biggest terrorists in
the world i said well
you know the thing about it is boss what
an opportunity to learn about them
you know i mean you just can't i'm here
to learn and even if it's an unpleasant
or
you're here to learn and i learned an
awful lot just about maybe the couple of
hours that i spent there listening to
that guy
just how good these folks are but
tremendous education and then from there
i went to become the deputy
sock pack so i had all of these
beautiful suits and overcoats and things
that i wore at that at harvard and then
you're not and then i'm in
you know aloha attire
don't throw anything away you never know
and then what you're doing the deputy
what's the deputy position like out
there in sock pack what are you doing it
was wonderful
um so uh in in in the pacific
uh sock pack was co-located in the same
building as the pacific commander
so we actually were although as separate
subunified command admiral prier who was
the pacific commander actually made us a
part of his staff
so well we we had the best of both
worlds
that in the morning you know it'd be up
there uh
because the general traveled a great
deal and i would be the one that
represented sit there
you know with the four star and his his
staff getting the
all of the classified briefings up in
the skiff and then down to
uh another conference room where a
broader audience with the
um less classified things were discussed
but going through um interesting things
uh with uh sending two carrier battle
groups into the taiwan strait um
and it's just seeing that unfold but we
also had a
a a situation where uh this was the
first time
i really became aware of beheadings uh
we had a group of westerners this is in
august of 95
on vacation through the hindu kush
and this was up in the line of control
in srinagar and they were captured
and held ransom by muslims up there
and one of the captures of norwegian
[Music]
ran away and they caught him and they
cut his head off they put
one his body on one part of the town
and the head on the other part of the
town with a ransom note
you know on either and the indian
military then
came to the ambassador who was the
senior ranking ambassador in the united
states state department then who went to
the secretary
uh and we had to deploy a delta force uh
assault team there with general pete
schumacher
who was the jsoc commander
so uh we were doing uh not commanding
control
for them because the specific command
was doing that
but there was nobody in the pacific
command that understood that
so i was standing next to the four stars
this before admiral prayer showed up
this was admiral mackey
and he had to draft a personal form
message to the secretary of defense and
to the chairman every day
and i drafted those messages for him
and you know he changed a little bit but
it was that
time i had in harvard i mean necessarily
i never would have been able to do that
before as i said spelling counted and
uh but you know he would change a couple
of things um
and uh they were deployed there for 40
some odd days
and um um uh we i we never got the
hostages back
so uh when when just they um
were there this now it is um
september so it is the anniversary
of uh uh the end of world war ii
and the the president is there uh the
secretary of defense
everybody's there to this is bill
clinton and and
this is so this is 95. so um
and now i've been locked up for 30 40
days
i'm as white as a sheet uh but because i
wasn't going anywhere
you know i'd go home for four hours and
sleep and shower and come back
i'm in my you know aloha i mean i'm in
my flip-flops i'm on my
board shorts and i'm in my t-shirt now
the pacific commander is down there with
the president and everybody having
breakfast but his aide
uh is up there and i've gotta run all of
these things by him
and i'm explaining said okay bur you
know what they're asking for is they
want to go forward
and be with the the indians are gonna do
a takedown and they want to have our
guys to be with them during
the takeout and i'm trying to explain it
to him uh and and
he's a you know an attack pilot and he
finally know
keep in mind he's in chokers with all of
his medals
and the big gold aguilettes that the
eighth wear and he finally says to me
i can't get this you got to come with me
all right so i'm following him
again flip-flop i got you know this bag
handcuffed to my hand
right and we jump in the car and as i'm
in the car i'm trolling i don't get it
you're just gonna have to explain it
yourself
now i i i completely forgot what was
going on
but as i get down there you got all the
secret service agents you've got metal
detectors
right and and you've got two air you've
got an aircraft carrier on one side of
the pier
and two cruises on the other right and
they're all a dressed ship
and everybody's standing along manning
the rail so
bud jumps out of the car and he just
runs through the metal detector and
they've seen him for several days and i
know he's good
and i come after him and there was the
secret service guys that come
i'm with him with him he's with me
so we're walking down the pier and um
uh so we're standing there and again
everybody's address ship i mean folks
you got to understand just how
impressive this is you know you've got
several hundred guys at an aircraft
carrier the cruiser you've got the flags
up
and then uh the armored vehicle comes
down initially
and these guys jump out it's all the
secret service guys
and then down comes um the beast
so the president and the first lady are
in that and then you hear
from the aircraft carrier a bugle
everybody for attention
right so everybody's attention and in
bud langston you know
he's saluting i'm in my flip-flops and
stuff
and the president gets out of the car
and i figured be inappropriate to salute
so i'm just waving
and the president comes up and he shakes
my hand
yes thanks mr president you know so
so if they go he goes on board the ship
the meanwhile
uh they he went on and then the rest of
them had to walk down so
down comes the secretary of the navy the
secretary of defense the four-star
commander
so bud goes okay you got to brief the
admiral so
we pulled him off to the side and i
tried to give him the disposition of
what they're asking for
and um what is your recommendation
captain
i said sir i think you need to support
the guys and
approve the decision well that's about
the stupidest thing i've ever heard
life do i get a second guess
he says no he said that thing will go
south and who are they going to blame
you know no joe you go back and tell the
general permission denied on that time
again i think in retrospect he's
probably right but
you know what do you think i guess
strong
but it was it was an interesting job and
the last thing that we did before i left
um is we had to evacuate cambodia
so there was a coup in cambodia and uh
the the embassy needed to be evacuated
um so we deployed uh to cambodia
and um uh that was the last thing i did
then i finally
uh left and then took over the center
and uh so
you know i was sleeping in my office
working around the clock just an
operational command
and now i take over the training command
and um
you know i've probably been there for a
month and a half and one of your
previous guests
bill mcraven is driving along the strand
it's about 7 30 at night he's going
one way and i'm on the other side he
takes his jeep and he makes a u-turn
he says joe what are you doing coming
home from work get in the car
so get in the car joe it's 7 30 at night
you're on show duty you're driving
everybody crazy
you got to take a deeper breath and
maybe just kind of pace yourself a
little bit more but joe
they can they they they're not keeping
up this pace here but
thanks for the feedback buddy i
appreciate that you know but you come
from an operational command when you're
doing something like that and
it takes you a while to decompress and
become a human being again
and how is buds from from now from the
perspective i mean the last time you
were there was as a student
yeah yeah now you're back there as the
as the senior guy
you know people talk about the changes
it bugs yeah and there's other people
that go hey look doesn't matter there's
little changes here and there but the
outcome is the same
yeah would you say um yeah i mean it
changed dramatically and that as i said
nobody really cared about the numbers
back then um
that if nobody graduated nobody
graduated
but at that time we actually
inappropriately so people were looking
for return on the investment
and um you know we we still had a really
terrible attrition rate but we also had
some other things that we did that
um you know when when i finished hell
week
you know i had to cut my boots up so my
feet
could fit in the boot um and you know i
had cellulitis
uh and just that's it i mean so and and
that was inappropriate that you know we
had to do that
but and then you know the the young
troops back then you know every day that
they'd come in and they changed their
socks out for them and give them dry
socks and just some other things but
i mean the mission of the command is to
qualified
uh to to graduate qualified individuals
to go to the seal team
not break them and bust them so you know
whatever it's going to take
to get them there but um it was it was
really
still pretty much the same but um uh
it needed a little bit of tightening up
just a little bit
so you know we had some instructors
there and what i just thought we needed
to do
uh you know you know i'm not too into
this as you know choco but i'm thinking
you know
i kind of have to drive a little bit of
fear into these guys just being
a little bit too relaxed so i went to um
you know the guys at the development
group
and i said can you send me a couple of
warrants or maybe some senior guys that
would like to come on out here and help
shape the community for the next couple
of years
so um we had some of the devgrew senior
realistic guys come out
and um so one of the guys showed up a
warrant officer
uh who's a dear friend of mine um and we
were one of the final days of hell week
and the kids are in the demo pit
and the kids are in a demo pit we're
setting off explosives around them
uh and these kids are still singing now
this is probably thursday or so i kind
of forget
and they've already lost about 100
people in the class
so these kids aren't going to quit but
they are they are beat up
and the instructors are doing their
thing and i mean he just
arrived at the command and i said hey
danny we're down there you want to come
with me down to the demo pit and watch
i said sure i'd like to come along so
you know i'm just doing there i've got
the master chief and i'm again i'm not
interfering
i'm watching and i look over at this guy
who is a
dev grew warrant officer and he's got
tears in his eyes
all right didn't say anything on the way
back uh
oh yeah i said danny how'd you feel
about that
i forgot he says i forgot what it was
like
he said i forgot he said i for a little
while i was there
and he said you know it so yeah it's the
same
um and you know
master chief defelski who was a streets
streetwise
uh forced master chief um and
uh he really mud sucked our instructors
so
you know we all go through training and
as we look back on it in the rear view
mirror
we were faster smarter stronger
better and so he's the the master chief
in charge of all of the
instructors uh at bud's training and
they're constantly complaining to the
master chief about the quality of the
individuals they're not making this and
if they don't do this they shouldn't be
able to contribute
so really is smart guy
uh on a friday afternoon we have one big
classroom
uh it probably seats about a hundred so
he's got all the instructors uh in there
he made everybody come it was mandatory
and he's got the the chalkboard up there
he said all right
first phase what is the minimum standard
that you need to have for the fourth
time
for the four mile run here and it went
down for the swim the yo course then
and the second phase third phase and
everyone wants everything to be you
got to do better got to be faster got to
be stronger so so
he he really mud sucked them so he said
let me understand this now he said chris
i'm going to go talk to the captain and
we're going to change things here he
said so but i want to make sure that
everybody agrees
if you can't do this in first phase if
you can't do that in second phase if you
can't do that in third phase you should
never be a seal is that correct that's
right master chief you're right
well gentlemen it just happens i have
every one of your training records here
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give each and every one of you your
training record
i'm going to walk out of the room once
you finish looking at it
and you see what you did just put it
back in the box
and i'll see you monday no because it
was true they you know it's humbling to
go back and look at your own record
and see what the instructors said about
you you know okay they stole it we still
have the same
we've got we've got this we've got every
single record
from day one uh on and so as a matter of
fact when i was there i i tried to
burn down the uh the the room there that
i kind of said
hey when did you leave buds what's that
when did you when were you done at buds
as the
commander well uh i i was i was there
for 39 months which is a really
good you know and honestly uh it was uh
just a fantastic uh tour not one that i
wanted to do
because i was gonna go someplace else in
virginia beach
and um uh we had trouble with our
attrition rate and getting folks through
so
i got uh changed from uh going out to
virginia beach to uh to
to the center but it turned out to be uh
probably
the most rewarding tour i ever had to
have people like marcus latrell
uh go through training and uh you know i
remembered marcus
uh because not many students break their
femur
uh in in training and uh so
you know it's not a good time when you
know the the senior instructors and the
doctor and the master chief come to talk
to you about
um all right uh he broke his
what he broke his femur uh how
stress fracture well
bs right so i mean we went through and
i'm going through this stuff
right so what happened was i mean
right i mean and they were covering for
him and he did break his femur
so i mean marcus if you listen to it
so the instructors you know and if any
of you think that you could beat me
of course marcus raises his hand this is
the obstacle course
so um we have it's all technique
and now you're dealing with a seal
that's been doing this obstacle course
for
years it you know and um now marcus was
good
but you've got a guy who you know these
guys are like pixies going over this
darn thing
so you climb to the top of the uh cargo
net
was that about thirty feet jacob's yeah
right and you throw yourself
over and and but you do it in a
technique that then
you drop down a little bit and you could
grab onto the rope and work your way
down
so uh marcus got that he knows that's
the technique
and he threw himself over the only
problem was
um he didn't grab it
and he went down to 30 feet and hit
and he broke his femur so i mean to his
credit though
went out got rolled back and came back
but i mean that that that's a good old
boy there
but they lied to me
as any good teammates should do because
you know because they didn't want
the instructor in trouble and and i
bought it unfortunately it wasn't until
later on that actually marcus told me
the story that i broke my life
he's the one that came clean you know
oh that's epic yeah this must be like
the uh
the the glimpse that you get at human
psychology one year because i never
worked at buds you know i went through
it but i never saw it from the other
side yeah the glimpse at human
psychology of what
people are capable of and what breaks
them and and
that's got to be a yeah that's got to
leave a mark well
absolutely and you know you literally
learn a lot
i mean now you know you and i go through
it but you go through it it's different
you're experiencing it
when you have an opportunity to watch
class after class after class
you know i just remember you know the my
first hell week class
and um this is monday night of hell week
so they start off at sunday they've been
at it for about you know
22 hours 23 hours they're having their
evening meal
and uh the class you know outside
and there's a couple of students staying
behind in the chow hall
putting the chairs back into the table
now i thought that this was somewhat odd
so i'm sitting there with the
instructors having uh uh dinner
i said so what are these guys up to yeah
they're just waiting for the rest of the
class to leave so they can quit
um and and and it was true so you could
just say but
what it was is nobody ever
quit in the evolution everybody quit
before the evolution in anticipation
of what was gonna happen and just
now uh you can argue whether or not it
is the most demanding physical
course in in the military if it's not
it's close
all right so i won't argue with anybody
but i will tell you this
it is a far more psychological program
than it is a physical program because
it's designed to keep you
off foot uh and that the standards
are raised and raised and raised or the
the you're told that this is going to be
the evolution today
and then they change it but specifically
to that can you adjust to that can you
adjust to that
um so it really it is
most of the people who fit quit no i
had a three and a half hour briefing
today down there with our teammates
an update on what the community's up to
and uh beef dressler
uh gave me the pitch and beef just took
over the center
on um on on friday and um
they bring in uh close to 900
uh students a year to get 180 out
187 is his demand signal and 900
so it's still in spite of everything
that we've done
in preparation as you said you know when
you went through nobody knew when i went
through it was a trivial pursuit
question
you know but now these these guys are
prepared they know what he's doing
and they all i said to them today what
is the what is it
they they self-select they raise their
hand and
they know we lose a couple from
academics uh we lose some from pool comp
but the vast majority of it this is not
for me
and when i used to get the young men in
the you know now i was not an instructor
and um and i would get them all after
the instructors talked about hell week
i'd go in there and i would just talk to
these guys
and marcus talks about that in his book
uh
i just look it's as simple as this guys
you know every one of you guys can make
it through
otherwise you wouldn't be here i mean
you've already been here now for several
weeks
if you're not going to make it you're
the one who decides you're not going to
make it
it's not going to be us at all and you
know
it's as simple as this guys i mean this
is surly the secret to life
is just don't quit just
don't quit i said don't doubt yourself
um and um you know these guys they they
doubt themselves but it's
why am i here and i used to say that
when they first came
what do you you know buds is not the
seal team
buds is buds it is where
why do you need to spend 26 weeks to get
where you want to go
but don't even think for a second that
this is
a seal team but i will tell you this you
put up with this for 26 weeks
and you get to that seal team it will
make everything that you did here
worthwhile trust me i was down there a
little while ago and uh
you know i was walking around and there
was just with one of my friends
that works there and there's a hundred
helmets by the bell
100 helmets by the bell and
he says you know what i said i said
that's a lot of quitters this you know
whatever it was
two weeks in i said that's a lot of
quitters and he says you know what
every one of those guys is a stud
yeah a st and he's he's basically
referencing compared to us when we went
through
you know when i went through i thought
if you did a a pull-up workout where you
did
30 or 40 pull-ups that that was a pretty
good workout and you don't realize when
you get the buzz you're going to do
300 or 400 or 5. you just didn't know we
didn't know back then
but every one of these kids now they're
studs
physical studs but they still quit oh
yeah
yeah but the difference though
physically i would say
is um you know when i went through eric
olsen bill mcraven was two classes
behind me
um the way eric put it and i think this
is right
back then uh it depends on your parents
were
if you're gonna make it two buds because
it was endurance everybody had to run
forever
and everybody had to swim forever back
then so it was a different type of body
type
now not everybody looks like you john
but
but yes you know when you know when when
i took over the center
and these young men lined up next to the
pool in just their their swimsuits
it was a completely different physique
on those young men
uh but we were preparing them for
different things as opposed to
no long-range patrols you know no no no
10 to 12 days in the field
no 13-hour swims you're going to go to
the hindu kush
and you're going to go to balad and
you're going to go to ramadi and you're
going to go to fallujah
and you've got to wear heavy equipment
and you've got to carry a lot of stuff
so
it changed and i don't know what's going
to happen now that you know we're we're
changing and admiral howard rightfully
so is going back into
uh strategic competition great power
competition and putting the community
back
uh into a maritime focus get those
wetsuits ready boys
absolutely uh did you you know it's
interesting
you know people always ask who's gonna
make it through who's gonna make it
through and i
would never put a bet on anybody one way
or the other
of who's gonna make it through or not i
don't care where they came from what
their background
was i remember one of one of my
commanding officers uh
uh captain o'connell he had he he told
this story to me and i i never forgot it
he had he there was some officer that
was put in a package to go to buds
and he said i've never backed anyone
before i've never i've never backed
anyone i've never said this guys to make
and this guy had this pristine record
he was an athlete this he was captain of
that he was all these things
he spoke two languages maybe even three
languages just a complete that and
finally
o'connell you know signs off his package
and says yeah take this guy to buds
and the freaking guy quit on him and he
said i will never
ever back anybody again and to me that
you know that was a captain that had
been in the teams forever
and denied all these packages and even
with that level of discretion
you can't tell who's going to make it
and who's not going to make it there's
jim jim
yeah yeah no
no you really can't because you really
don't know what's going
on behind the eyes so um we've got
members who are on the national teams
um whether it's the national swimming
team nice you know these are
very accomplished people division one
athletes and but the other thing as well
you get some kid that comes out of high
school goes to boot camp uh did
intramural sports
and he's standing tall on graduation day
yeah that's me
100 100 and i had a i had a
i had an olympic alternate gymnast in my
buds class
quit and i had the ncaa
water polo team captain in my class
quit yeah and like like i was that guy
that i was an
average if not slightly below average
athlete in high school and
hey stuck it out they weren't going to
make me quit that's the way it is yeah
where were you when uh when september
11th happened i was assigned united
states special operations command
um and excuse me
i was assigned the united states special
operations command and you know
we talked a little bit earlier choco
about the community uh
and what the fleet commander said
what my father said and here i am
i got promoted to one star um at the end
of august
uh of 2001. wow and um a little more
than three weeks later
i'm sitting in my office united states
special operations command
and um you know one of the the troops
comes
and he leans against the the door jamb
and i said what's up
he said a plane just hit the uh twin
tower so
you know you know being a new yorker and
i'm thinking okay you know this is foggy
day and you got a small aircraft there
and he's not leaving uh yeah and i'm
just figuring
okay i got a tv i said do you want to
turn the tv on
i guess i'd like yes sir so i'm behind
the desk i've got the tv over there
and i look up i go it is a perfectly
beautiful day in new york and
i mean shortly after that i mean with
moments
i see the other plane flying south on
the hudson river
you don't fly south in the hudson river
the plane's going into newark
you got to fly north or you got to go
around and i'm thinking what an
idiot that guy's flying that plane
around just to get a better look at that
how stupid
and then boom he goes into the second
tower
uh and i mean immediately and i get up
and i ran into the socom commander's
office
uh general uh holland
and i said general we're under attack
we're at war
he said what are you talking about joe i
said turn the tv on
i said we're we're at war and um so
obviously that was a long day to kind of
sort everything out
and i finally got home
uh about maybe one o'clock in the
morning two o'clock in the morning
of um of the 12th and uh so
i'm just having a little bit of orange
juice and maybe an english muffin or
something try to get a couple hours
before i got to go back into work and
the phone rings
and uh i pick up the phone i figured it
was the headquarters
and there's the shrill voice on the
other side uh it just kind of screaming
and all of a sudden i realize it's my
brother
and my brother was at 220 church street
which is a block down from the twin
towers
and he was at a meeting and
saw the first bill he didn't see the
plane hit but he saw the
the building on fire i said well maybe
we should adjourn
if you know i mean again nobody could
believe that it was happening
and you know he said so by the time they
adjourned he went out to the street
you know he actually you know viewed you
know the people
jumping for their lives out of the twin
towers which is pretty traumatic
but then he had to walk home across the
brooklyn bridge
all the way to his home which probably
wound up being well i don't know maybe
about 12 to 15 miles
uh because there was no transportation
everything shut down so by the time he
got home that's when he calls me
and it kind of broke down to joseph get
them
i know what you do it's up to you guys
get them
i think i'm just trying to calm them
down um because
oh okay bob i'll do my best you know
and um so uh one i never thought i'd be
an admiral
never uh and i certainly never thought
i'd be an admiral
when our nation was at war and uh to
have
that opportunity to you know actually be
a flag or general officer serving in the
united states military when the nation's
engaged in
decisive combat operations was you know
quite an honor but also a you know quite
a challenge
and you know it took us a while but we
finally
we finally did it and after it and uh
may 2nd of 2011 i called my brother
and it took a while bob but we got him
and i'll tell you what when that
happened i know i retired
uh in july of 2010 and
um i'm up early in the morning uh not as
early as you but probably about 5 30
and um i'm i'm in the kitchen
and uh you know got a little bit of cup
of coffee as i'm putting my running
shoes on
and i thought i heard something on the
radio about
bin laden i mean i just wasn't paying
attention
that doesn't i so um
i just waited till six o'clock to hear
the news
and you know folks who stayed up late
the night before they knew
and i still had no idea and i heard what
had happened
and um i was just thinking
i mean i just sat down there
i couldn't go for a run i mean i just
had tears in my eyes
um and that i know full well and so do
you
the heavy road the toll that was paid
to get to a badabad all of the blood and
all the lives
and all the the brave men and women you
know who got there
and so and by the time i got to work you
know everybody's jubilant
and um as saying you know
i had quiet pride it was probably
because it was our teammates
and then the 160th and the cia but um
it was really emotional for me just
thinking about
whether it would be matt axelson danny
deeds uh
or all of the other folks that uh you
know uh bourgeois
uh uh all all the men that we lost there
uh in afghanistan
and um so yeah that was uh
you know people be getting my hair cut
and how long you've been in the navy
uh 36 years well how'd you stay so long
you know we've been at war for the last
10 years buddy you know and uh it was on
our shoulders
uh but um you know when you
know full well this war
was personal to you and me and to many
of us and the other thing as well
it's just hard to explain to people how
you could become
friends through death that you meet
parents
and you meet family members that you
never
knew but you knew their son and you
buried their son
and you were on your knees giving a
mother
the flag that was on her son's coffin
and
you get to know these people and you
stay
close to them you know for for a long
long period of time
so um and i wound up there at socom
and um you know it was an interesting
time for me
it was a baby baby one star and it was a
small place
we uh only had five uh five flag of
general officers then
the four star the three star two green
beret two stars and me i was the baby
uh but um we it was a great place to
learn
and one of the offices there eldon
bargewell uh was a special forces
general officer and up until that point
eldon was the most highly decorated uh
soldier in the united states army
and um you know school was certainly in
session uh for me uh you know work
working with eldon so that when i left
there and then
um went to naval special warfare to take
over the community
i left there as the deputy commander
under admiral eric olsen
and came back you know close to four
years later and i just remember
uh you remember captain barbara ford uh
just
said after that she goes oh my god you
turned into an admiral
you know you had to yeah so
my uh my commanding officer at seal team
seven
i was on deployment i was in iraq having
just the best deployment ever just
having a great time doing a bunch of
operations and and he says to me
the last thing i do as commanding
officer of steel team seven is i'm gonna
make sure that you become the admiral's
aide
he pulled it off so that's why that's
how that's how you ended up with me
well i tell you what it was wonderful
you know um you know between
uh you and um you know and beef dressler
uh you know folks out there you know
you've got a good idea what choco looks
like i'm sure
but uh beef used to be the center for
navy and uh he's also
uh a pretty pretty strong guy well my
name is jaco
his name is beef i know kind of says it
all
but when when when when uh jocko uh beef
was replacing jocko we had the families
over for dinner
and uh we're there at dinner and my
daughter uh
is sitting there and she's probably
about 10 at that point time
and she looks at the two of these guys
and she honestly asks
beef and jocko uh are you guys my
daddy's flag lieutenants or
you guys my daddy's bodyguards and the
two of them go
yes i said you guys screwed up you
should have told me
my daughter your daddy doesn't need a
bodyguard but the truth of the matter is
i sure did
and if i had one these are the two guys
that could do it
but um no i you know what what i what i
always asked i never interviewed anybody
to be the the
the flag lieutenant out there folks what
i would do just go to the senior
officers
i go send me a champion send me somebody
who's just come out of combat somebody
somebody who's got a future ahead of
them somebody somebody who's willing to
work
really hard and because
i you know don't use the flag lieutenant
in the aid to carry my bag i carried my
own bag
what i needed was to bring a lieutenant
into the meeting
to hear what was being briefed or what
was needed to be resourced
and be able to turn to that lieutenant
and say do the men need this
is this what they want well what do they
want that we haven't
and you know i rick because that
individual whether it was uh you know
choco or beef
came right out of the battlefield uh and
had that credibility
it was only a year their they're turning
the barrel and it's a very demanding job
i had been a flag lieutenant myself i
understand that but
um it was just choco
was a tremendous resource for not only
me but the community
and then as well when choco then went
back into you know his seal team and
became a test unit commander
he almost becomes like an apostle to the
rest of the community to explain
why we do what we do because now he knew
he'd been to the inner sanctum
but uh it was an absolute honor and you
know the way i considered
to be uh you know you and me our
relationship is just like in any
relationship in the teams we were swim
buddies
and necessarily we had each other sex we
had each other's back but
i leaned very very heavily on you and
you never never never let me down
you always came through choco yeah and
then um
obviously when we were going through
that deployment in ramadi it was just
awesome
like i s like i started off you know
this the support that you gave
me and there there by the rest of my my
task unit was just
it was awesome well you know
we were a community at war it was on our
shoulders and i know that you were
taking it very hard
uh because you know we were taking some
heavies
but um when you're at war you have to
realize
you're at war and um you know there's
going to be
um casualties and but you know at the
end of the day
uh you were highly successful in your
mission and you came out of that with
extreme high regard but um you know to
me
you know several years later as you know
um we're christening a
navy land attack cruiser up in bath
maine
and one of one of the great honors that
i've ever had
was normally when you christen a ship i
mean everybody's there senators
congressmen
and the secretary of the navy is the
guest speaker the main speaker
and because of my relationship with with
with mikey monsoor
uh and with you and test test unit
bruiser
uh that the secretary of the navy asked
me to be the guest speaker there
but uh i think i also mentioned to the
speaker you know it was tasking the
bruising if you got any questions on why
we call it that look at lieutenant
commander wellington
well that's awesome uh i know we
probably could talk for another few
hours and i know that you got to go
which pretty much to me means at some
point you got to come back and we can
tell the rest of your story uh
because this was not the end of your
career of service
and you ended up doing much more and um
yeah we you'll have to come back and
next time you're in coronado
we'll come up and finish the rest of the
story yeah well i'll tell you jacko
i'd i'd love to come back and we've had
a great visit here in coronado with the
uh center change of command visiting uh
our teammates
uh spending you know three and a half
four hours getting briefs from on the
committee this morning it's just
inspirational but
um you know i believe in a life of of
service and um
uh and as far as a leader is concerned
you know you've got to be a you know a
leader who sacrifices
of you know and when i was asked to come
back in the government
wasn't on my scope at all but uh i came
back in
and uh you know wound up being the
director of the national
counterterrorism center
which i was very comfortable in that it
was my strike zone uh
but then when the president asked me to
become the director of national
intelligence
not necessarily my strikes on him there
but i will tell you
uh to to start off and have a rubber
boat in your head
uh and and then years later you know
you're sitting there as the president's
intelligence officer
uh at the national security council and
even you know i had a
an interesting time there as i'm sure
you know that i i had a testimony
uh there for three and a half hours on
the house um
select committee on intelligence it had
to do with the whistleblower complaint
but you know for three and a half hours
you're on camera and you've got some you
know
very very bright and talented people
asking you some demanding questions
but it was uh the very first time that i
was really really happy
that i went to high-risk seer and
understood interrogation techniques
so i'll tell you what uh even as that i
knew that was happening and i sat down
to watch it and i
and and you can you know they look like
sharks in the water you can see them
they're they're thinking they're gonna
go you don't know who you got number one
he's from brooklyn number one number two
he's in the teams
harvard the whole nine yards i said this
isn't gonna go as well as they think
it's gonna go
no i didn't uh you know i'd say what um
no i may not uh it was it was because
i will tell you this though uh choco
there um
not only was i representing the the
entire united states intelligence
community
but having spent 36 years in our
community you know i really feel like
you know here i am i know i'm on
national tv and it's going to be a
a pretty important hearing which
probably would lead to
what it did um and i just forgot i'm
still representing
the united states navy and our special
operations community
so i just figured all i'm going to do is
tell the truth and play it straight it's
as simple as that
and and and i did and um
i i think at the at the end of it i felt
like
i did my job and i was able to leave
with my head held high
yeah well that was the other thing i
knew i knew you were from brooklyn i
knew you were from the teams
i knew that you went to harvard in the
whole nine yards but i also knew
that if they were looking for something
that you had done
that was immoral illegal or unethical
i knew that they could not find it and
they would not find it because
i i know you and i know that you do the
right thing
and so that's why i watch that with uh
with great joy yeah well
well just before i got the job it was uh
the white house chief of staff mick
mulvaney did the
the vetting uh and uh you know mick told
me said you know i've talked to
everybody especially everybody in the
special operations community
and i couldn't find one person to say
something negative about you
now i hadn't been offered the job yet i
said mick give me a day i'll give you a
list of people
i did i don't necessarily want that job
but i got it and it went okay but jaco
has been a great honor it's
so good to be with you uh and it's
always good to be with the teammate but
i'm so proud of you
for not only what you did when you were
in uniform but uh you know what you have
accomplished as far as just not only
personally but the way you've been
offered to give back with your
leadership and
what you're sharing with the world
whether your books your podcast
and there's so many people that i know
that listen to this podcast read your
books
and really learn a great deal about
leadership and
you know folks i tell you um when people
ask me do i know him i do
is either you know is he is the real
deal he's the real deal
and uh uh i'm honored more than i could
possibly tell you to be with you today
and folks
you know i do plan on taking choco back
up on this offer and come back
and visit with you sometime in the
future so thank you my friend be
outstanding and and the things i say
today are the things i learned from
people like you
from our great community and thanks for
coming to talk to us
more important thank you for everything
that you've done for america
for the navy for the teams and of course
for me it was an honor to serve with you
and i look forward to talking to you
again likewise jaco thank you
and with that admiral joe mcguire has
left the building
and echo you didn't even get a chance to
sort of ask a question we were
moving pretty quick and he had another
event to attend so you have to save your
whatever did you have any questions
uh not at the moment i actually asked
the one what's the the lockout
thing there's a lot of little stuff man
that you know
that i'm like hey wait what is that not
even necessarily because i don't
know what it is and i need clarification
a lot of times it's like
i don't know what that is but it sounds
kind of interesting maybe not to you
guys because that's part of your guys
everyday thing at the time but for me
it's like man even that lockout thing
bro that's interesting
and i'd i think it's one of those things
where imagine if you were
hearing a jiu jitsu story about like
you're caught in an arm lock and you
were
then they had the triangle too and you
were and you all i would need to tell
you
since you know jiu jitsu if i was like
hey i was caught in the arm lock
and the triangle both at the same time i
started having the walls close in
you would know what that meant yeah
someone that doesn't understand jiu
jitsu is just like oh
like kind of it doesn't really mean that
much to them in fact it almost means
nothing to them
so when the admiral was talking about
that whole walk out thing in the german
u-boat yeah
that is a crazy story that is a crazy
story
the cold the the the claustrophobia
the changes in pressures did that come
across could you recognize
how freaking crazy that was yeah so it
it did come across but you know what
else was clear to me that
that what you're explaining right now
that was the case and and i did not want
to interrupt at all i mean
aside from at least so i can grasp an
understanding of what the lockout
procedure is so i know even more
but yeah so the claustrophobia thing
anytime you guys talk about submarines i
do remind myself because my friend jared
jeremy would tell me about like these
submarines and there's those little
diver vehicle
things or whatever so seal delivery
vehicles
yeah so he'd tell me about that and it's
like bruh it's not like
it's not like cool like on the movies
you guys are cruising in the office with
the thing bro the thing is like
super cramped and super and brad i don't
like that claustrophobia
stuff yeah i know you don't we'll put it
this way i'm attuned
to certain cramped yeah um 21 inch tube
yeah i see 21 inch tube yeah
yeah so you guys are talking about that
and i'm like boom and then yes then you
guys are talking about like these
procedures like kind of like oh we all
know what those procedures are
i'm like wait a second we have
claustrophobia you got freaking the
submarine you're underwater you're doing
all this stuff bro
i kind of want to hear more it's kind of
nuts you know but that's not that wasn't
the point that he was making
at the time so it's like i don't want to
derail the momentum for the conversation
yeah well uh at some point maybe we'll
go into a little more detail about what
those types of operations are like i was
lucky
because when i came in to the teams we
still did that
in the normal teams and once the war
kicked off we didn't really do
submarine lockouts in the normal teams
very often if at all
not to mention we used to just dive like
it was going out of style
like it was going out of style and once
again once the war started we're
fighting in iraq and afghanistan we're
not doing a bunch of
combat swimmer dives to prepare training
dives to prepare to go to iraq
like there's some rivers but we're not
doing harbor infiltration
on draeger's that's but i was lucky
enough to be able to do that
a bunch a bunch and just get some of
that
get some of that it is a freaking hard
job man
it's a hard job you mentioned something
uh kind of
kind of in passing like kind of quick
where
you you have the operation but all the
steps
to go through the operation are just
complete painful like completely painful
so like you know you talk about the
temperature of the water
if you haven't swam or been in
40 30 something degree weather i have
ice bath scenario whatever but
nonetheless i know what that feels like
on that pro what if that was just your
world you know
what's your world that's your world and
that was what was interesting he was
talking about getting into the submarine
after jumping out of an airplane and
then landing in the middle of the ocean
then you lock into the submarine going
one person goes in fin first it's crazy
and by the way then you're just on the
submarine you still haven't even done
the mission yet you're not even close
darkness you're not even close you
haven't even started the mission yet
yeah but yeah and so yeah so it's like
that kind of stuff where it's like man
you could elaborate on the feeling of
like a 10 second period
for a long time and really paint that
picture that would be interesting
that'd be nuts yeah we'll have to get to
it at some point
nonetheless as you like to say we uh
we we might not be in those scenarios
but we want to be ready
for various scenarios we want to improve
our
capabilities for diving swimming
shooting living fighting whatever we're
doing
whatever we're doing that's true how do
we how do we improve our capabilities a
little bit here and there what do you
think echo charles where should we start
interestingly you talk about diving and
swimming i bought a madness a few months
ago so
i didn't know that masks for like
you know diving stuff had like that many
levels too no there's less you know
bro there's like some good masks anyway
but i got a good one and i was like
all right makes you kind of want to go
swimming more too by the way
so it's like when you get these things
you it kind of
pushes you into the game a little bit
more right
i'll give you an example all right so
what are we doing we're working out
we're reading
we're listening true
when i say working out there's various
kinds of workouts obviously there's jiu
jitsu there's weights
running cardio med cons all this stuff
nonetheless you can take some damage on
the way got some doms right now
by the way squats yesterday
and conditioning nonetheless you might
need supplementation
so good news is jaco has supplementation
so first we'll start with the cognitive
and physical stuff
discipline go
kind of groundbreaking in a way very yes
so let's start with the cans so energy
drink boom it's the new energy drink
already
established already yep the new one the
new wave the new paradigm
isn't it funny there was all these other
companies making quote energy drinks
and none of them saw this big just giant
gap in the market they were just saying
oh we'll put more sugar and more
caffeine yeah
and and and more people will buy it yeah
and they didn't see this big hole a
bunch of people actually wanted to drink
things that were healthy
and actually gave them real energy not
just a freaking
sugar rush multiplied times a a caffeine
jitter
and call that energy so anyways they
didn't see it cool we did
here we are yeah and i get it cause like
you know as a
company or whatever like you kind of
some let's just say some groups kind of
play off of
weaknesses of our brains or whatever and
go for that
superficial um you know whether it be
palatable
you know just that easy that easy win
you know tactical
and they can play off of that and you
can get some good numbers with that
that's the thing so they play on like
people's weakness
in a way play on the short term
gratification of human beings
yes so if you could you know if you call
that a weakness will play on their
weakness right but
the good thing about this is you don't
play on people's weakness
you actually play on their strengths to
be honest with you you help their
long-term strategic goals oh yeah but
you
but the good thing or one of the many
good things about this is that it's both
short-term
and term it's amazing discipline go the
energy
and actually the one that is the most
short term
payoff as far as taste goes is the mango
factually speaking even though you're
drinking a whoop ass watermelon
you ran out using short supplies
i will say this one thing that's cool
about these drinks the different flavors
taste
actually taste different it's not like
the
some other quote energy drinks that
you can there's a bunch of flavors but
they're all just basically tastes like
sugar water
yep whatever yeah you know um
it's been a long time since i had any
other energy drinks but
yeah i can remember that that was kind
of the case one way or another
nonetheless okay so this lingo this is
if you haven't gathered already it's a
healthy energy drink that you will you
will literally be better off
after you drink it than before you drink
it and it fulfills all your energy drink
needs
very legit very legit there's also like
the mix
discipline go the mix mix it up with
water whatever on the go and capsules
so keep this in mind first cognitive and
physical
supplementation in general also get your
immune system
in check vitamin d3 we got some cold war
we got the joint
maintenance and repair kind of both in
one
get some joint warfare get some krill
oil uh and of course
of course glory be to the protein gods
we have monk
yep that's true brad if you're trying to
and here's the thing
i don't know if we talk yeah we talk
about this where yeah if you're trying
to like build muscle which i think is a
very
worthy goal but we're we are in support
of building muscle
you want more muscle you want less
muscle right the
not dichotomy what do you call the
simple decision what do you call that
kind of decision
binary decision right you want more you
want less all right so if you want more
you need
extra protein to add to the muscle that
you're
trying to build so do you know the
minimum amount of protein you need
uh one gram per pound of lean body mass
oh jaco coming off the top ropes with
some bro science from 1996. from what i
understand that's on the high end
for sure okay well but keep in mind
let's round it up right
well let's say what let's say the
average let's say someone weighs 180
pounds okay
so you need a 180 grams of protein
you know how much protein that's a lot
there's a lot of protein there's a lot
of steaks
in one day and steaks are pretty high in
protein so i'm saying
yeah so the milk
this serves is this serves that purpose
very well here's a good thing about milk
like we already know it
actually tastes good like an actual
dessert so now you can have
two desserts in one day you'll be better
off than you were and if you're trying
to build muscle boom facilities you can
have breakfast dessert
lunch dessert dinner
dessert snack dessert get yourself some
mold but you get all this stuff
jackalful.com
if you subscribe if you want to get it
shipped to your house for free subscribe
at jockofield.com we'll send you all the
stuff that you order for free
you can also get the drinks at wawa on
the east coast
vitamin shop you can get all these
products as well and and a lot of people
hitting me up like hey can you get this
drink you know in milwaukee and in
tucson
and in la we're working across the
country we're literally having meetings
all the time
to get this stuff propagated throughout
the nation
because we don't want we want everyone
to be stronger faster
smarter and better yeah so
we'll let you know as we as we get out
there yeah it is about the long term
and being prepared 100 also
origin usa so you go to originusa.com
this is where you can get
your american made stuff apparel
got some boots on there boots and jeans
they'd say that's the what he called a
flagship
kind of scenario yes
there's some jiu-jitsu stuff on there
pete was on there he's demonstrating or
how should i say displaying showing
whatever
some new pants the new orc pants yeah i
got them
[Music]
they're freaking legit bro they're so
stoked brothers so there's some you were
talking about wet suits
earlier today and to me this is kind of
the
the image i got is like you were talking
about those old wetsuits and
your new high-speed wetsuit it's kind of
like a source yeah
yeah so these pants that's pete pete was
showing their little video that's the
new work yeah
so it's like oh if you get regular work
pants cool and it's cool
it's better than your workplace it's
actually not it's like having one of
those old wetsuits
yeah but it's better than no wetsuit is
what i'm saying marginally
okay they're that and that's my point
and there's no reason to it's not like
there's going to be
um you know there's no reason to back in
the day it was hey this is the cheapest
government contractor that can build us
wetsuits that suck
and then other manufacturers are out
there making
bad ass wetsuits but we didn't get them
yet so there's no reason for that oh
yeah
so now you got the same deal boom you
want the new the the updated
effective work pants this is this is the
kind of stuff origin does
straight up that's the game we're gonna
make everything by the way oh yeah
everything uh also make geese and hey if
you want to put your ghee
to the test come to the origin main
jiu jitsu camp retreat
intensive immersion yeah immersion camp
that too
and here's the thing about that too
because some sometimes people be like oh
is that is that thing just
super intense or like what is that
that's freaking fun what's up like three
you just did three times two times
whatever a day
they're like man like i like jiu jitsu
but
i don't know if i'm down for these you
know this hell weak navy seal
uh 30 of the people that are there will
have
less experience in jiu jitsu than you
even if you only have
two weeks of seriously yeah and there'll
be some freaking awesome
badass black belts and brown belts and
purple belts for sure
but there'll be a lot of people that are
just getting their start in jiu-jitsu so
come and check that out if you want to
origin check originusa.com
yeah and it's not like it's this big
competition training all the bra
and i'm not going to name any names and
actually it's cool
you can go there and not not spar with
people
go there just learn learn the technique
talk with some people
go swim in the lake straight up like
it's a jujitsu vacation that's what it
is straight up we should have called it
the jujitsu vacation yeah
yeah and and you could even call it
depending on your
your your intent going there you could
call it a vacation with some level of
jujitsu depending on what you're
curious about whatever level jiu jitsu
you are you can go level 10
you go level 10 yeah you can train three
times a day you can travel
you could train probably 14 hours a day
if you want to yeah and you just you
know you could train zero
zero it's up to you yeah and it's just
kind of a it's a
vacation with some level of jiu jitsu
involved
if you want and lobster and lobster and
steak
so check it out originusa.com also uh we
have a store by the way yes what's that
store called echo
it's called jackal store so anyway
jocklestore.com is where you can get
your shirts and hats and hoodies light
and heavy
rash guards on there some shorts on
there i'm gonna update some shorts
get some new shorts on there too are the
ones that i've been asking for yes okay
that's good to know as soon as those
come out
i need five pairs okay just kind of fyi
you got it just kind of fyi
hundred percent there's a lot of cool
stuff on there discipline equals freedom
good anything when you want to represent
while you're on the path are the new
shorts gonna be
the same material as the old shorts you
tell me
i say yes because their material is good
to go yes sir i agree i agree
um yeah so yeah some shorts on there as
well um
yeah if you want something get something
that's a good way to represent also
we have the shirt locker it's a new
shirt it's a subscription situation
new shirt every single month different
designs that is
they're good designs you're hired for
sure
that was a great week we collectively
have been struggling to demonstrate or
to explain
the the uh the quality of these new
designs
did you say we got some cool designs
they got some we do you could have said
that
yeah well said you said there but that
does something that doesn't capture it
they'll see
because every time people are like hey
that design is cool can i have it
and i'll be like well that was two
months ago okay that's what i'm saying
so i got to convey it accurately so
people know going in
it's an element of trust for sure
check it out the shirt locker yep it's
on jocko's store hey also subscribe to
this podcast
don't forget we have some other podcasts
we got jocko unraveling with daryl
cooper we got the grounded podcast
which we haven't done in a long time we
got the warrior kid podcast and we also
have the jocko underground podcast
jockowunderground.com if you want to
subscribe to that thing
and get on board and help us build the
underground where we're going to be
laying in weight in things if things go
sideways we'll be there
we're stockpiling material
sure we got food we got water we got
content yep jocko underground.com if you
want to check it out out eight dollars
and 18 cents a month
some people know what that eight dollars
and eighteen cents
represents not many though
take a guess and if you can't afford it
hey look we we want you in the game even
if you can't afford that eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month
we'll still just email assistance at
jockowunderground.com
and we'll take care of that
also we have a youtube channel we have a
youtube channel where
uh a lot of the videos some of the
videos i should say some of the more
premiere videos have
i'm the assistant director on and it's
very obvious when they're awesome
you know's funny they uh i i released a
video
recently mango mayhem mango man
so people are catching on to the whole
assistant director thing
why are you saying like that because
well
because people i think give might give
you
uh well then again i guess it's not
undue credit because
the author i know you say this is kind
of a joke but
like every once in a while you'll add
like a little detail
i had a critical detail that turns out
to be kind of critical
so okay so in that video it hurts you so
bad it hurts you so bad that
whatever i add is usually critical okay
so here's the thing
you're you're right in a way it doesn't
hurt okay we'll use the word hurt it
hurts me not because oh joko did it
thought of it i didn't it's more that
jocko thought about it
it's hard to be like if i was writing a
book about leadership
and then you added you're like hey you
need to discuss this thing
right here and i couldn't not do it
because it made so much sense i
could and and you know what my ego would
be affected by that
that's okay that's where you're at
that's the part like i'd well maybe it
is but i don't
feel overtly that it's my ego it's more
that like oh shoot i didn't even see
that
like frick how can i be so stupid how
can i be so stupid how could i be so
pathetic no no no how can i not be
better better not a loser so you know
you know
like you you walked up like in that
video you walked up right at the
beginning when you walked up and you're
doing this
this part yeah yeah like that that was
pretty good i gotta give it to you i'll
send it to you
assistant director jocko over here
you can subscribe to that and we also
have an album that's called
psychological warfare that will help you
get little moments
get through little moments of weakness
i'll kind of get in your head a little
bit
press play go to your mp3
platforms to get some of that if you
need a visual representation of the path
cool we got that for you too well dakota
meyer does
flipsidecampus.com got all kinds of cool
stuff to hang on your wall i've written
a bunch of books
the the latest edition oh i don't have
it on my table
it's final spin it's a
book i mean it's hard to describe it's a
transcript
it's it's a novel it's a poem we don't
even
the publisher doesn't know what to call
it they never seen anything like it all
they know is that it
it they they are impressed all they know
is that they are emotionally
moved by this piece of work so if you
want to get some of that
order it now final spin get that first
the dish
you're going to want the first edition
of that because listen hey i'm going to
write another leadership book but guess
what that's another leadership book
so even though you get the first dish of
a new leadership book it still is the
first of a dish of a
series of leadership books if you want
to get in early
on the novels the first dish leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
quality evaluation of protocol displays
freedom field manual
way of the warrior kid one two three and
four
mikey and the dragons about faced by
hackworth i wrote a little forward to
that what an honor that was and then
the og's extreme ownership and the
dichotomy leadership
that i wrote with my brother leif babin
we also have a
leadership consultancy called echelon
front where we
solve problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details
ef oh sorry extreme ownership
academy go to extreme ownership dot com
if you want to get if you want to go to
the leadership gym
leadership you don't learn leadership in
one day or by reading one book
you got to get in the gym you got to be
consistent go to extremeownership.com
check out our online training platform
all kinds of activities going on there
we also have a live event next one is
phoenix
august 17th and 18th we are
not sold out yet people are a little bit
nervous some people i guess
about miss rona but
we are getting close so that's phoenix
august 17th and 18th after that is las
vegas october 28th and 29th
those have all sold out in the past
these will too
get him in on it early go to
ashlandfront.com check the events
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families
check out mark lee's mom you heard about
mark lee today what a freaking hero he
was and his mom
has been carrying on his heroic
attitude with her charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you well let's face it if you
want
any more of my tedious testimonies
or you want to have for some reason you
want to hear
more of ekko's ridiculous reflections
you can find us
on the interwebs on twitter on instagram
which i can only refer to as the gram
and facebook
echoes that echo charles and i am at
jacqueline lincoln thanks once again
to admiral joe mcguire for coming on
for sharing his experiences but more
important
and i think you realize this thank you
to the admiral
for your incredible service to our great
nation
and the rest of the military out there
right now
army navy air force marine corps
thank you for your service as you
protect
freedom and democracy around the world
and the same goes to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all the
four first responders out there
thank you for protecting us here at home
and to everyone else out there
think about the impact that you can have
and and yeah think about it your own
life and you want to have a positive
impact in your own life but
think about the positive impact that you
can have on others
think about what you can do by reaching
out to people by supporting them
by doing like admiral mcguire did for me
by being there for people by helping
them
shoulder some of that weight
it isn't about you it's about the team
support your team support your family
your friends your community
by going out there every day and getting
after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out